WELCOME TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON HUMAN SERVICES HEARING FOR
CARING FOR CARE GIVERS OF OLDER
ADULTS RECOGNIZING.
THAT BENEFITS NEEDS OF FAMILY
CARE GIVERS.
THIS IS OUR FIRST HEARING WITH
THEIR NEWLY FORMED COMMITTEE
MEMBERSHIP SO I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU IN THE COMING YEAR.
IT'S GOING TO BE AN EXCITING
YEAR AS WE CONSIDER POLICY THAT
WILL HOPEFULLY IMPROVE THE LIVES
OF SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CITIZENS.
TODAY WE'RE FOCUSING ON THE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
CARE GIVING FOR OLDER LOVED ONES.
OFTEN WITHOUT EARLY WARNING OR
PREPARATION AND WITHOUT PAYING.
AGING ACCIDENTS AND ILLNESSES
TOUCH ALL OF OUR LIVES.
WHEN PEOPLE BECOME INJURED ILL
HORTON FROM DATE OFTEN NEED IN
HOME ASSISTANCE WITH TAX LIKE
BABY IN SHOPPING OR ATTENDING
MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS?
WITHOUT THIS ASSISTANCE MANY
WOULD END UP IN NURSING HOMES OR
YET HOSPITALIZED.
IT IS DURING THESE CIRCUMSTANCES
ONE FAMILY MEMBER STEP UP AND
PROVIDE THE CARE NECESSARY TO
KEEP LOVE ONCE IN THEIR HOMES.
CARE GIVING WHILE OFTEN VERY WAR
NEAT REWARDING CONSTRAINT CARE
GIVERS FINANCES HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH.
WE ARE HERE TODAY TO EXPLORE THE
SYSTEM OF SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
AND ITS IMPLICATIONS FOR FAMILY
CARE GIVERS.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS
ANOTHER VERY IMPORTANT TYPE OF
FAMILY CARE GIVERS THOSE CARING
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES THE
COMPLEX SYSTEMS THAT SERVE OLDER
AND ADULTS AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES OFTEN
TOUCH ONE ANOTHER.
AND CARE GIVERS IN BOTH SYSTEMS
ALSO FACE THE MERRY OUT OF
CHALLENGES.
SOME OF WHICH MAY BE VERY
SIMILAR TO THOSE DISCUSS TODAY
WHILE WE RECOGNIZE THE
INCREDIBLY INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
ROLE ALL FAMILY CAREGIVERS PLAY.
TODAY'S HEARING FOCUSES ON THE
NEEDS OF FAMILY CARE GIVERS FOR
OLDER ADULTS.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE MY FELLOW
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AN OPPORTUNITY
AN OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE OPENING
STATEMENTS.
THANK YOU US SENATOR HER TAUGHT --
CONGRATULATIONS ON BEING ON THE
CHAIR OF THIS WONDERFUL
COMMITTEE AND I'M HONORED TO BE
YOUR VICE CHAIR AND AND TO WORK
WITH YOU I THINK WE WILL HAVE A
PASSION --
FOR PEOPLE WITH SPECIAL SPECIAL
NEEDS WHETHER THEY'RE YOUNG
PEOPLE OR OLDER PEOPLE --
HAVE BEEN THE GRANDFATHER OF A
SIX YEAR OLD --
ARTISTIC --
CHILD WHO I I LOVE TO PIECES --
I OBVIOUSLY WANT TO SEE WHAT I
CAN AS A AS A LECTOR OFFICIAL
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
ASSUME THAT.
HE'S GETTING THE BEST CARE SHE
POSSIBLY CAM I HAVE TO REGIONAL
CENTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PARTICULAR IN AND
REGIONAL CENTER.
AND AS YOU ALL KNOW WE HAVE --
THE SOBRE SU NOMINEE SADDAM
COMING ON OF WHICH I'M A MEMBER.
AND SO -- WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT OUR ELDERLY
CAN GET THE APPROPRIATE CARE
THAT THEY NEED ESPECIALLY WITH
THE THE INCIDENTS THAT WE SEE OF
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AND
BASICALLY WERE SAYING PARENTS
COMING BACK TO LIVE WITH THE
KIDS AND THE THE WONDERFUL.
IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM WHICH I SAW FIRST HAND
AS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR IN THE
BENEFITS THAT IT.
PROVIDES IS --
IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT SO I LOOK
FOR DEPARTING WITH YOU WITH THE
REST OF THE COMMITTEE TO DO WHAT
WE CAN.
TO HELP THOSE PEOPLE THAT --
ARE VULNERABLE AND ANY --
ASSISTANCE AND CARE.
AND I'M DELIGHTED TO SERVE HER
WITH YOU.
THANK YOU CENTERS.
THANK YOU FOR THOUGHTFUL OPENING
REMARKS AND LET'S CALL UP OR
FIRST PANEL WHICH WILL PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF THE CARE GIVER
LANDSCAPE.
WE WILL SET SET A TIME LIMIT FOR
EACH PANELIST AT FIVE TO SEVEN
MINUTES WE ASKOUR PALACE TO
COMPLETE THE PRESENTATIONS AND
THEN WE WILL OPEN. FOR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS PANELISTS
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND
TELL US YOUR AFFILIATION WHEN IT
IS YOUR TURN TO PRESENT.
MR PRINT EVIL PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY [inaudible] FOR
CALLING [inaudible]
I'M.
NINA AND AS LONG AS WELL PLEASE
IF YOU DON'T MIND COMING UP
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
HEAR ME OKAY.
OTHER THREE THINGS I WOULD LIKE
YOU O TAKE AWAY FROM MY
COMMENTS TODAY.
THE FIRST AS IT'S BEEN TOUCHED
ON IS THAT THE EXPERIENCE OF
AGING IN FAMILY CARE GIVING
IMPACTS ALL OF US.
THE SECOND HIS IT WALK CARE
GIVING DOES IN FACT IMPACT ALL
OF US THERE ARE SOME ISSUES THAT
ARISE IN CERTAIN COMMUNITIES
THAT MAKE THE IMPACT IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES EVEN MORE INTENSE.
AND FINALLY WE AS A STATE CAN
AND MUST TAKE BOLD ACTION TO
BETTER SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
FAMILY CARE GIVERS AND THE OLD
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES THAT THEY SIR.
I'M KEVIN PRINTED ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THAT JUSTICE
AN AGENT WE'RE A NONPROFIT LEGAL
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION THAT USES
THE POWER OF LAW TO FIGHT SENIOR
POVERTY.
WE WORK TO ENSURE THAT STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTSARE
PROVIDING THE RESOURCES AND
SERVICES THAT ARE NEEDED BY A
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE GROWING OLD
AND POVERTY.
ESPECIALLY THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE MORE LIKELY TO GROW OLD
AND POVERTY INCLUDING WOMEN.
PEOPLE OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS IN
LGBT KEEP.
IN ADDITION A CARRYING ABOUT
THESE ISSUES --
BECAUSE OF THE WORK I DO
PROFESSIONALLY THEY'RE AWESOME
ALSO ISSUES THAT HAVE IMPACTED
ME PERSONALLY --
MY MOTHER PASSED THIS LAST
SUMMER AND FOR THE FIVE YEARS
PREVIOUS TO THAT I WAS ONE OF
HER CARE GIVER SAYS SHE LIVE
THROUGH A TERMINAL ILLNESS.
AND I SUPPORT MY FATHER WHO IS
HER PRIMARY CARE GIVER.
SO I THINK YOU FOR YOUR INTEREST
IN A COMMITMENT TO THESE ISSUES
ARE AGING AND DISABILITY
ADVOCACY COMMUNITIES ARE
THRILLED TO HAVE SUCH COMMITTED
PARTNERS WORKING TO TAKE NEW
ACTION IN BOLD ACTION TO BETTER
SUPPORT THE COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
NOW AS I SAID THE EXPERIENCE OF
AGING IN THE FAMILY CAREGIVING
IMPACTS ALL OF US IT'S REALLY
THE PERFECT ISSUE THROUGH WHICH
TO EXAMINE.
AGING POLICY ISSUES BECAUSE YOU
CAN REALLY SEE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE CARE
GIVER HOW AGING IMPACTS NOT JUST
THE OLDER ADULT OR THE PERSON
WITH THE DISABILITY BUT THE
ENTIRE FAMILY THE COMMUNITY.
THE GOVERNMENT'S EMPLOYERS ARE
ECONOMY EVERYONE IS IMPACTED
MANY OF US IN THIS ROOM HAVE
PROVIDED CARE TO A FAMILY MEMBER --
NEEDED CARE FROM A FAMILY MEMBER.
AND IF YOU HAVEN'T YET YOU
LIKELY WILL AND IF YOU HAVEN'T
YET YOU KNOW SOMEONE WHO HAS
SOMEONE ELSE IN YOUR FAMILY A
COLLEAGUE OF FRIENDS YOU KNOW
FAMILY CARE GIVERS THAT ARE
GOING THROUGH THESE ISSUES RIGHT
NOW IN THEIR LIVES.
IN FACT IN CALIFORNIA THERE'S AN
ESTIMATED FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION FAMILY CARE GIVERS THAT
PROVIDE SERVICES WORTH AN
ESTIMATED FIFTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
CALIFORNIA LIKE THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY IS GROWING RAPIDLY --
THE AGING POPULATION IS GROWING
RAPIDLY OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE SIXTY FIVE
AND OVER IN THE STATE WILL GROW
BY FOUR MILLION AND IT'S A TREND
THAT CONTINUES.
INTO THE TIME WHEN I WILL BE IN
OLDER ADULTS SO I'M PART OF THE
SILVER SNOBBY AS WELL THIS IS
NOT A ISSUE THAT'S JUST
RESTRICTED TO PEOPLE.
THAT ARE OLDER NOW OUR ON THE
COST OF BECOMING OLDER IT'S KIDS
AND GENERATIONS TO COME.
AS OUR POPULATION AGES WE ARE
SEEING AN INCREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF OLDER ADULTS THAT NEED LONG
TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT ARE SIXTY
FIVE AND OLDER 70% WILL NEED
CARE TO REMAIN SAFELY AT HOME.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE COST OF
CARE IS ON AFFORDABLE BUT ALL TO
ALL BUT THE WEALTHIEST OF
CALIFORNIANS AND MY COLLEAGUES
WILL GO INTO SOME MORE DETAIL
ABOUT THOSE NUMBERS.
AND WE DON'T HAVE IS A STATE A
PROGRAM THAT WILL COVER THOSE
COSTS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
MEDICARE HAS A WONDERFUL HEALTH
CARE PROGRAM BUT IT COVERS ONLY
LIMITED LONG TERM CARE.
MEDI CAL DOES COVER LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS AND IN
FACT AS THE PRIMARY PAYER OF L.
TSS IN THE STATE.
BUT IT'S ONLY AVAILABLE TO
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME PEOPLE OR
TO MIDDLE INCOME PEOPLE AFTER
THEY'VE EXHAUSTED ALL OF THEIR
INCOME AND ASSETS TO QUALIFY FOR
THE PROGRAM.
AND EVEN THEN IT DOESN'T COVER
EVERYTHING THAT PEOPLE NEED.
SO IT'S IN THIS CONTEXT THAT
FAMILY CARE GIVER STEP UP.
AND THEY PROVIDE THE CRITICAL
FUNCTION THAT THEY DO --
THEY HELP IN A WIDE VARIETY OF
WAYS LARGE AND SMALL THEY HELP
WITH RUNNING ERRANDS AND GETTING
TO DOCTORS APPOINTMENTS THEY
HELP WITH ACTIVITIES OF DAILY
LIVING LIKE BAITING AND
TOILETING DRESSING EATING AND
MORE.
HELP WITH MEDICATION MANAGEMENT
AND HEALTH MONITORING.
THE HELP WITH MEDICAL CARE THEY
ADVOCATE WITH DOCTORS AND
HOSPITALS AND THEY DO THIS ALL
TO SUPPORT THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
SO THEY CAN STAY AT HOME IN THE
COMMUNITY.
THAT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO
THAT'S WHERE PEOPLE OR AS THEY
HAVE MORE COMPLEX NEEDS.
BUT IT'S ALSO GOOD POLICY FAMILY
CAREGIVERS HELP KEEP PEOPLE AT
HOME WHICH SAVES THE STATE MONEY.
BECAUSE IT'S MUCH LESS EXPENSIVE
TO CARE FOR PEOPLE AT HOME THAN
AND MORE COSTLY INSTITUTIONS.
BUT FAMILY CAREGIVERS DO ALL
THIS AT TREMENDOUS COST MENTAL
COST EMOTIONAL COSTS PHYSICAL
COST AND ECONOMIC COST TO
THEMSELVES.
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND TO OUR
KEEP OUR ECONOMY.
THEY MISS OUT ON WAGES THEY
SPEND MONEY OUT OF THEIR OWN
POCKET TO PROVIDE THIS CARE.
AND ECONOMIC COSTS FEEDING
INTERGENERATIONAL CYCLE OF
ECONOMIC AND SECURITY AND
POVERTY IN MANY FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
SO THAT BRINGS ME TO MY SECOND
CRITICAL POINT.
WALK CARE GIVING IMPACTS ALL OF
US IT IMPACTS SOME OF US MORE.
THE PROCESS OF CARING FOR A
FAMILY MEMBER IS AN EXTREME
CHALLENGE EVEN FOR THE
WEALTHIEST FAMILIES.
AND IT'S EVEN MORE OF A
CHALLENGE THAT'S COMPOUNDED BY
ECONOMIC AND SECURITY FOR LOW
INCOME AND MIDDLE INCOME
FAMILIES.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST RATE OF SENIOR POVERTY
IN THE COUNTRY. ONE IN FIVE
SENIORS IN CALIFORNIA'S LIVES IN
POVERTY.
AND EVEN MORE ARE JUST ABOVE THE
POVERTY LEVEL.
STRUGGLING TO JUST MEET BASIC
NEEDS LIKE HOUSING AND FOOD AND
TRANSPORTATION.
SO IMAGINE GOING THROUGH THE
DIFFICULTY OF PROVIDING --
IN CARING FOR A FAMILY MEMBER
WITH A LONG TERM IF YOU ALSO ARE
WORRIED ABOUT HOW YOU WILL PAY
THE RENT OR HOW HE WILL AFFORD
FOOD THAT MONTH. ONE FAMILY STEP
IN TO HELP.
WITH THE ECONOMICALLY AND SECURE
OLDER ADULTS THAT JUST DEPLETES
THE INCOME AND ASSETS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO THE WHOLE FAMILY.
AND INCREASES THE CHANCES THAT
THE NEXT GENERATION THAT FAMILY
AND THE ONE AFTER THAT WILL ALSO
AGENT THE POVERTY.
IT'S IMPORTANT OUT THAT ANOTHER
POPULATION THAT'S PARTICULARLY
IMPACTED BY CARE GIVING IS WOMEN.
WOMEN PROVIDE 60% OF A FAMILY
CARE GIVING SERVICES IN THE
STATE IN THE COUNTRY ACTUALLY
AND WOMEN AVERAGE THIRTEEN YEARS
OF NO EARNINGS.
DUE TO CAREGIVING
RESPONSIBILITIES.
THE RESULT IS THAT WOMEN ARE
MORE THAN TWICE AS LIKELY AS MEN
TO AGE INTO POVERTY.
ANOTHER GROUP PARTICULARLY
IMPACTED BY FAMILY CARE GIVING
ARE BLACK AND LATINO X. FAMILIES.
WERE CARE GIVER SPEND AS MUCH AS
40% OF THEIR INCOME ON CARE
GIVING EXPENSES.
AS WITH WOMEN THE ECONOMIC COSTS
OF CARE GIVING FOR THIS GROUP
CONTRIBUTE TO HIGHER RATES OF
POVERTY AS THEY AGE.
SO MY THIRD AND FINAL POINT WE
AS A STATE CAN AND MUST TAKE
BOLD ACTION TO BETTER SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S FAMILY CARE GIVERS
AN OLDER ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
THAT THEY CARE.
FOR CALIFORNIA HAS SEVERAL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
ASSIST IN SUPPORT FAMILY
CAREGIVERS BUT MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS.
HAVE NOT BEEN EXPANDED TO KEEP
PACE WITH GROWING NEEDS AND IN
SOME CASES THEY'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
CUT BACK.
SO NOW IS THE TIME TO IMPROVE
AND EXPAND THESE PROGRAMS
INCLUDING EYEQ ASSESS THE
COORDINATED CARE INITIATIVE.
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES
THE EMPHASIS P. PRO IS THE
EIGHTY ARE SEIZE LEGAL SERVICES
AND MORE.
AND AS WE SEEK TO BETTER SUPPORT
FAMILY CAREGIVERS WE NEED TO GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT WE'RE
DOING TO TODAY WE NEED TO THINK
BOLDLY AND TAKE ACTION TO CREATE
A MASTER PLAN FOR AGING HAS BEEN
CALLED AS HAS BEEN CALLED FOR BY
THE GOVERNOR.
AND BY OTHERS IN THIS BODY.
AT PLAN SHOULD INCLUDE SUPPORT
FOR FAMILY CAREGIVERS AND ALSO
IN OCCURRED INTERCONNECTED
ISSUES LIKE ELDER ECONOMIC
SECURITY.
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY ORAL HEALTH CARE I
JUST SETS IMPROVEMENTS ELDER
ABUSE THE PAGER CARE GIVER WORK
FOR SOME MORE.
THE PLAN TO PLACE IT CENTER
ISSUES OF EQUITY HOW CAN WE
DESIGN OUR SYSTEMS TO ADDRESS
SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES.
THAT RESULT IN DRASTICALLY
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES AND
OUTCOMES AMONG OLDER PEOPLE AS
THEY AGE.
AND HOW CAN WE CREATE PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES THAT ARE CULTURALLY
AND LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE.
WE MUST INCLUDE NEW IDEAS THE
WILL PROVIDE IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO
CARE GIVERS LIKE MAKING IT
EASIER TO QUALIFY FOR MEDICARE.
IMPROVING ACCESS TO ORAL HEALTH
THE CONTINUED DEVELOPMENT OF
INTEGRATED PERSON CENTERED CARE
SYSTEMS AND INCREASED ACCESS TO
EIGHT CBS.
AND FINALLY WE MUST BE WORKING
TOWARDS AN AMBITIOUS NEW PROGRAM
FOR FINANCING AND PROVIDING LONG
TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS LIKE
THE ONE INTRODUCED EARLIER TODAY
BY SENATOR PAN.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
AN EFFECTIVE PROGRAM FOR
PROVIDING LTE ASSESS WILL PRIOR
PRIORITIZE KEEPING PEOPLE AT
HOME.
RELIEVING THE ECONOMIC BURDEN
PLACED ON FAMILY CAREGIVERS
CREATING IT FAIR AND JUST WORK
ENVIRONMENT FOR PAID CARE GIVERS
AND SAVING LOW INCOME AND MIDDLE
INCOME FAMILIES.
FROM HAVING TO SPEND ON ALL OF
THEIR INCOME AND ASSETS TO JUST
TO GET THE HELP THAT THEY NEED.
WITH LEADERS LIKE YOU COMMITTED
TO THESE ISSUES WE NOW HAVE A
GOLDEN OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
ACTION AND TO ADDRESS A
COMPELLING NEED IN OUR FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING THANK YOU FOR YOUR THE
SHIP WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
YOU KNOW WHY THE HER WELL WITH A
OR P. ASSOCIATE STATE DIRECTOR.
HERE ON BEHALF OF WE'RE ACTUALLY
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING FIFTY PLUS
CALIFORNIANS WE HAVE NEARLY
THREE POINT THREE MILLION
MEMBERS.
BEFORE YOU START I WANT TO JUST
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS
INTEREST IN THIS ISSUE AND THE
EXCELLENT REPORT THAT IT CAME
OUT OVER THE WEEKEND.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW REFRESHING
IT IS TO HAVE A COMMITTEE THAT'S
WILLING TO ROLL UP ITS SLEEVE
AND FLEE THE BEGIN NOW THIS
COUNTIES IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS.
SO WHAT I'M GOING TO DO TODAY IS.
KEVIN PROVIDED EXCELLENT
OVERVIEW SO I WON'T REPEAT A LOT
OF THE DATA BUT I DO WANT TO
TALK ABOUT --
FREE MY REMARKS WITH.
I THE HIGH COST OF LONG TERM
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES OR L. T.
ASENATH.
BECAUSE IT REALLY PROVIDES THE
CONTEXT.
IN PART WHY WE MUST RELY ON
FAMILY CARE GIVERS TO PROVIDE
CARE FOR BOTH OUR AGING AND
DISABLED FAMILY MEMBERS.
BUT IT ALSO REALLY TELLS US THE
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE ANOTHER CHOICE.
AS KEVIN NOTED MEDICARE PROVIDES
LIMITED BENEFITS A LOT OF PEOPLE
CAN'T QUALIFY AND WHERE YOU HAVE
TO SPEND DOWN TO QUALIFY FOR
MEDI CAL.
THE SIMPLE FACT IS AN THIS IS
ACCORDING TO A OR ANY OTHER
PEOPLE REPORT THAT WAS JUST
PUBLISHED LAST YEAR.
L. TSS COST MORE THAN MOST
CALIFORNIANS.
CAN AFFORD.
THE AVERAGE OLDER CALIFORNIAN
HOUSEHOLDS HAS A MEDIAN INCOME
OF FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND ONE IN THREE ACTUALLY 36% OF
OLDER CALIFORNIANS OVER.
SIXTY FIVE LIVED BELOW 210050%
OF THE POVERTY LEVEL IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN AT THE SAME TIME.
MOST FOLKS REQUIRED OR WOULD
NEED TO SHOULDER THE BURDEN OF
HIGH COSTS SUCH AS A HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
FOR A PRIVATE NURSING HOME ROOM
IN A NURSING FACILITY AND NINETY
SEVEN THOUSAND FOR A SHARED ROOM.
EVEN LOOKING AT SAY ASSISTANT
ASSISTED LIVING THAT BASE COST
IS FIFTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR THAT'S THE SAME AS THE
MEDIAN INCOME --
EVEN IF HOME HEALTH CARE THIRTY
HOURS A WEEK.
IS ACCORDING TO A A RP ESTIMATES
THIRTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR.
AT THE SAME TIME I KNOW
SOMETIMES I HEAR FOLKS SAY WHAT
ABOUT LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE I
THINK MOST MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE NOW.
LESS THAN 5% OF CALIFORNIANS
HAVE LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE IS
NOT A VIABLE OPTION.
THAT MEANS THAT CAL OLDER.
OLDER AND DISABLED CALIFORNIANS
HAVE TO RELY ON A FAMILY CARE
GIVER IF THEY HAVE. ONE TO HELP
THEM WHEN THEY ARE NEEDED IN
NEED OF ASSISTANCE AND OF COURSE
FEW CAN AFFORD TO PAY TO PRIVATE
PAY FOR KIM.
WE THEN PUT THIS BALL GO FAMILY
CARE GIVING ON THESE FAMILY CARE
GIVERS MOST OF WHOM WORK --
AND IS KEVIN NOTED ESTIMATES ARE
NEARLY FOUR AND A HALF MILLION
CALIFORNIANS OR FAMILY
CAREGIVERS.
SO YES MANY FAMILIES DO THIS OUT
OF LOVE AND DUTY.
AND THEY DO THIS IS ALSO BECAUSE
THEY BELIEVE THIS IS WHAT WE'VE
ALWAYS DONE.
IT SAYS HOW ON A SHOW RESPECT
AND HOW I PAY MY PARENTS BACK
FOR HOW THEY HELP ME BUT THAT'S
A TREMENDOUS BURDEN. TO CARRY
WHEN YOU WERE IN THE AVERAGE
FAMILY CARE GIVER WAS FORTY NINE
YEARS OLD WORKING THIRTY FIVE
HOURS A WEEK.
IN ADDITION IT'S NOT JUST THE
FACT THAT FOLKS ARE WORKING BUT
OUR RESEARCH FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN
FOUND THAT THE AVERAGE FAMILY
CARE GIVER FOR AN OLDER
INDIVIDUAL.
SPENDS NEARLY SEVENTH A POCKET
EVERY YEAR.
AND FOR SOMEBODY CARING FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL WITHOUT SUMMERS AND
OTHER DEMENTIAS IT'S OVER TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
A RESEARCH ALSO FOUND THAT
LETTING NECKS.
CARE GIVERS SPEND OVER NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS YOU.
IN ADDITION OUT OLDER STUDY FROM
MET LIFE FROM EARLIER THIS
DECADE FOUND THAT THE LOST WAGES
FOR YOUR TYPICAL CARE GIVER.
WAS OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A THAT DOESN'T EVEN
COUNT SAY THE LOS SOCIAL
SECURITY BENEFITS.
WE KNOW THAT CARE GIVERS HAVE
REPORTED EMOTIONAL PHYSICAL AND
HEALTH RELATED STRAIN AS WELL.
WE ARE PUTTING A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF BURDEN ON OUR CARE
GIVERS ASKING TO AWFUL I ASKING
WAR IMPLYING THAT THEY SHOULD BE
THE PRIMARY SUPPORTER FOR AN
AILING FAMILY MEMBER.
BUT MOST ARE GETTING VERY LITTLE
SUPPORT --
FOR EXAMPLE OR CAN GIVE A
RESOURCE CENTERS.
WHICH IS ONE OF THE FEW STATE
SOLELY STATE BASED PROGRAMS THAT
HELP FAMILY CARE GIVERS.
THOUGHT CUTS OF OVER 75% BACK
DURING THE RECESSION IN THE
MONEY HAS NOT BEEN RESTORED.
HE BELIEVES WE CAN KEEP DOING
THINGS THE SAME WAY.
NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF THESE HIGH
COSTS BUT BECAUSE WE ARE
APPROACHING THE POINT WHERE
THERE WILL BE AS MANY PEOPLE
OVER SIXTEEN AS UNDER NINETEEN
THAT COMES UP IN. SIX YEARS.
END AN EARLIER STUDY BY A. R. P.
ALSO FOUND.
THAT A RATIO OF PAID AND UNPAID
OR INFORMAL CARE GIVERS WENT
WELL DECLINE PRECIPITOUSLY IT
WAS ABOUT SEVEN TO ONE IN.
TWENTY TEN BEFORE TO ONE IN.
TWENTY THIRTY AND THREE TO ONE
BY.
TWENTY FIFTY SOME OF THIS COULD
BE BECAUSE FOLKS ARE HAVING
SMALLER FAMILIES WE ALSO KNOW
FROM SOME OF OUR OWN DATA THAT
27% OF OLDER ADULTS ARE ACTUALLY
LIVING ALONE SO.
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE CARE GIVERS WE
CAN'T KEEP.
EXPECTING IT TO BE A FAMILY CARE
GIVER THAT IN ADDITION A SMALLER
FAMILIES OF COURSE THE GROWING.
POPULATION OF OLDER CALIFORNIANS
GROWING NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES ALONG WITH
OTHER PHYSICAL AND COGNITIVE
DISABILITIES ARE REALLY LEAVING
US AT A POINT IN TIME WERE NOW
IS THE TIME TO ACT.
SO WE WE WANT TO ALL WRAP OUR
ARMS AROUND THIS TOGETHER.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO GO FORWARD
WE BELIEVE IT'S NOT WE CANNOT
WAIT ANY LONGER --
WE MUST ACT NOW --
AS KEVIN NOTED A OR P. --
IS A BIG SUPPORTER OF SB FIVE
TWELVE INTRODUCED BY SENATOR PAN
WHICH WOULD HELP.
TO CREATE A LONG AN L. TSS
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT WERE ALSO LOOKING A
LEGISLATION TO EXPAND PAID
FAMILY LEAVE FOR FAMILY
CAREGIVERS. TO EXPANDED SO THE
MORE FOLKS HAVE JOB PROTECTIONS.
WAGE REPLACEMENT IS HIGHER
FUNDING FOR A CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS AND REALLY I'M
LOOKING AT A COHESIVE HOLISTIC.
MASTER PLAN ON AGING SOARED JUST.
TO DOES THE CAP OFF FOREVER OR
MARKS WERE DOT IT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE REALLY CANNOT WAIT
ANYMORE WE MUST GO FORWARD.
TAKE BOLD ACTION AND I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR HAVING
THE SHIRT TODAY [inaudible] FOR
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M HAD LONG TIME
ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING
SO LONG TERM CARE.
AN AGING SERVICES DIVISION WHICH
IS THE PROGRAM SIDE OF OUR
DEPARTMENT --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY AND
TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF INTRODUCTION
TO OUR PROGRAM THAT'S MOST
FOCUSED ON K. FAMILY CARE GIVERS
WHICH IS THE FAMILY CARE GIVER
SUPPORT PROGRAM UNDER TITLE
THREE EASY OF THE OLDER
AMERICANS ACT --
THE FEDERAL OLDER AMERICANS.
TWO THOUSAND ESTABLISHED TITLE
THREE E. THE NATIONAL FAMILY
CAREGIVER SUPPORTPROGRAM WHICH
FOCUSED ON HELPING FAMILIES TO
PROVIDE CARE FOR RELATIVES AT
HOME.
THE PROGRAM PROVIDES GRANTS TO
STATES AND TERRITORIES BASED ON
THEIR SHARE OF THE TOTAL
POPULATION OF THE NATION'S
POPULATION OF PEOPLE SEVENTY AND
OLDER --
CALIFORNIA'S FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN FAMILY CAREGIVER
SUPPORT PROGRAM FUNDING --
IS A LITTLE OVER. EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS EIGHTEEN POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
THE FEDERAL SHARE OF THE FAMILY
CARE GIVER SUPPORT PROGRAM
FUNDING.
OF MAY NOT EXCEED 75% OF
CALIFORNIA'S TOTAL FAMILY
CAREGIVER SUPPORT PROGRAM COSTS.
THE NON FEDERAL SHARE MUST BE AT
LEAST 25% OF STATE PROGRAM COSTS.
THE CALIFORNIA WORKS WITH A
NETWORK OF THIRTY THREE AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING TO DELIVER.
SERVICES TO OLDER CALIFORNIANS
AND THEIR FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
THE FIFTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES AND THE LOCAL AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING PROVIDE THE
NON FEDERAL MATCH.
WITH THE LOCAL FUNDING OR IN
KIND CONTRIBUTIONS.
NO STATE GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
ARE ALLOCATED TO CALIFORNIA'S
FAMILY CAREGIVER SUPPORT PROGRAM --
FAMILY CAREGIVER SUPPORT PROGRAM
SERVICES SUPPORT FAMILY AN
INFORMAL CARE GIVERS AND HELP
OLDER ADULTS TO REMAIN IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THE PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO
EMPOWER CARE GIVERS.
REDUCE CARE GIVER BURDEN.
ENABLE CARE GIVERS TO REMAIN IN
THE WORK FORCE PRESERVE AND
PROMOTE UNPAID.
FAMILY CARE GIVER NETWORKS AND
PREVENTS FOR DELAY.
THE CARE RECEIVERS NEED FOR
HIGHER LEVELS OF CARE.
THE FIVE PROGRAM SERVICE
CATEGORIES ARE INFORMATION FOR
CARE GIVERS ABOUT THE AVAILABLE
SERVICES.
ASSISTANCE TO CARE GIVERS IN
GAINING ACCESS TO SERVICES.
SO SORT THE SUPPORT SERVICES
LIKE INDIVIDUAL COUNSELING.
SUPPORT GROUPS AND CARE GIVER
TRAINING TO ASSIST CARE GIVERS
AND MAKING DECISIONS.
AND SOLVING.
PROBLEMS ARISING FROM CARE
GIVING.
RESPITE CARE TO RELIEVE CARE
GIVERS TEMPORARILY FROM THERE
CAN FOR CAREGIVING
RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND THE LIMITED SUPPLEMENTAL
SERVICES THAT ADDRESS UNIQUE
NEEDS THAT THREATEN THE CARE
GIVERS ABILITY TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING CARE FOR EXAMPLE --
INSTALLING SAFETY RAILS AND GRAB
BARS.
PURCHASING ASSISTIVE DEVICES.
AND PURCHASING OTHER SERVICES
THAT MAY BE UNIQUELY ADDRESS THE
CARE GIVERS NEED TO PROVIDE
SERVICE.
THE OLDER AMERICANS ACT REQUIRES
THAT EACH TRIPLE A ENSURE THAT
ALL FIVE SERVICE CATEGORIES ARE.
OFFERED IN ITS ITS PARTICULAR
PLANNING IN SERVICE AREA EITHER
AS DIRECT SERVICES.
OR THROUGH SUBCONTRACTS OR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER PUBLIC
OR PRIVATE AGENCIES.
THE OLDER AMERICANS ACT AS RE
AUTHORIZED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
SPECIFIED THE FOLLOWING
POPULATIONS BEING ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE SERVICES.
ADULT FAMILY MEMBERS OR OTHER
INFORMAL CARE GIVERS TO PROVIDE
CARE TO PEOPLE OVER.
SIXTY OR PEOPLE WITH ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE AND RELATED DISORDERS OF
ANY AGE.
RELATIVES OVER FIFTY FIVE YEARS
OF AGE THAT ARE NOT PARENTS.
WHO ARE CARING FOR CHILDREN
UNDER?
EIGHTEEN AND THE OTHER WHERE
RELATIVES INCLUDING PARENTS WHO
CARE FOR A PERSON OF ANY AGE
WITH DISABILITIES.
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA'S FAMILY
CAREGIVER SUPPORT PROGRAM SERVED
ABOUT FOURTEEN THOUSAND CARE
GIVERS.
OF OLDER ADULTS WERE ADULTS WITH
DEMENTIA AND RELATED DISORDERS.
THE TYPICAL CARE GIVERS SERVED
WERE WE IN THE AGES OF SIXTY AND
SEVENTY FOUR THE PROGRAM ALSO
SERVED ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FIFTY CARE GIVERS GIVERS OF
CHILDREN.
OR CARE GIVERS OF AN INDIVIDUAL
WITH A DISABILITY.
THE TYPICAL CARE GIVERS SERVED
IN THAT PROGRAM WERE ALSO WOMEN.
BETWEEN THE AGES OF FIFTY FIVE
AND SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AT
THE MOMENT BUT OFFERING ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FIFTY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
ACTUALLY --
SO LONG -- I
APPRECIATE THE THE WORK OF OUR
AGING --
AGING AGENCIES AND OUR
DEPARTMENT AGING --
BUT I ALSO AM STRUCK AS YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE SIZE OF YOUR
BUDGET.
AND THINKING ABOUT THE SCALE OF
THE PROBLEM IS YOUR BEEN.
A AND THE AND AT THE MADE
REFERENCE --
A DAY AND SOME OF THE FINANCING
THINGS FOR A LONG TERM --
SERVICES AND SUPPORT BUT IN
TERMS OF MAY THE SERVICES YOU'RE
FOR TO THAT --
THAT -- YOUR
AGENCY IN THE AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING ARE PROVIDING --
WHAT PORTION OF THE NEEDS ARE
YOU ACTUALLY ABLE TO SERVE WITH
THE RESOURCES YOU HAVE I MEAN
IT'S IT'S THE AGENCIES TO DATE?
MANAGE THEIR DOING GREAT WORK
ABOUT I'M JUST --
I ALSO WONDER ABOUT SCALE
[inaudible]
OKAY MIRROR.
HI I THINK AN ANSWER TO THIS
QUESTION WHAT WHAT YOU FIND WITH
THE NATIONAL FAMILY CAREGIVER
SUPPORT PROGRAM OVERALL IS THAT
IT.
IT TOUCHES ON A SMALL PORTION OF
THE NEED I CAN'T GIVE YOU AN
EXACT PER PERCENTAGE.
BUT IT'S IT'S CERTAINLY GIVEN
THE TESTIMONY WE'VE HEARD TODAY
AND AND THE DOCUMENT THAT HAS
BEEN PROVIDED.
THERE IS NEED TO BE BEYOND WHAT
IS.
IT AND WHAT EFFORTS AND I KNOW
THIS IS A NEW ADMINISTRATION BUT
HAVE BEEN DONE TO TRY TO AT
LEAST TO FIND WHAT THE I'D SAY
IS THEN --
DOMINATOR WHAT IS THE ACTUALLY
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE NEED WE
ARE PROVIDING I KNOW THAT --
THE GOVERNOR BROWN RECEDING
GOVERNOR DID SIGN.
IN THE LAST STATE BUDGET FOR A
STUDY THAT YES --
LEASE SOME OF THIS BUT THE T.
SPEAK TO ANY OTHER EFFORTS TO
TRY TO ACTUALLY THE FINE SO YOU
CAN GET.
YOUR HOPEFULLY HAVE SOME DATA
ABOUT WHO YOU'RE ACTUALLY ABLE
TO TOUCH CURRENTLY --
BUT THEN --
TO TRY TO HAVE A BETTER
ASSESSMENT OF HOW MANY PEOPLE
YOU ACTUALLY SHOULD BE TOUCHING
I MEAN ARE THE BUT THEN PUT
DEMAND IS OUT THERE TO YOU CAN
YOU SPEAK TO THAT.
I I'M I'M.
I THOUGHT.
THAT WAS AS OAKS ARE I'M NOT
PREPARED TO SPEAK TO THAT AT
THIS TIME I DIDN'T COME UP WITH
THAT AND I HAVE I MUST SAY I'VE
BEEN AND I AM THE ACTING DEPUTY
DIRECTOR I'VE BEEN AWAY FOR A
FEW YEARS.
AND I'VE --
I'M BACK TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FOR A COUPLE MONTHS.
BY APPRECIATE THAT --
YOU'RE BACK IN YOUR HELPING OUT --
PERHAPS --
AND WHETHER IT'S YOURSELF OR
SOMEONE ELSE --
THE CHAIR HERE AND I AM BOTH
SERVE ON OUR BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
AND I THINK SHE CAN SPEAK FOR
HERSELF TO BUT I WOULD BE VERY
INTERESTED IN HAVING ANSWER THAT
QUESTION BY THE TIME.
THIS ISSUE COMES UP BEFORE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE AS WELL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE AREA AGENCIES ON AGING.
DUE TO LOCAL NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL --
I'M NOT.
AS I CAN SAY CONVERSANT RIGHT
NOW AND WHAT AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING HAVE DONE WITH REGARDS TO
THEIR LOCAL NEEDS ASSESSMENT IN
THIS AREA BUT THAT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
I THINK AREA AGENCIES OF MAYBE
CLOSER TO A DETERMINATION OF
WHAT NEEDS ARE IN THEIR AREA
[inaudible]
YOU'RE WELCOME.
THANK YOU CENTER BANNER I DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
GRATEFUL THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY OF GREAT
INFORMATION TO KNOW AND WE
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK AND
DEDICATION --
YOU BRING TO THE ISSUE.
NEXT WILL CALL OUR SECOND PANEL
SO THAT.
WE CAN LEARN ABOUT THE CARE
GIVER NEEDS AN IMPACTS OF CARE
GIVING.
ONCE AGAIN WE WILL SET A TIME
LIMIT FOR PANELIST AT FIVE TO
SEVEN MINUTES EACH AND THEN OPEN
FOR QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO ASK PANELIST
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES AT THE
BEGINNING OF THEIR TESTIMONY.
THAT DR BENTON PLEASE START
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
AND WE CAN ALSO HAVE BETSY BUT
FOR AND BEVERLY AND BARBARA.
AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
FOR YOU'VE HEARD FROM UP A
REALLY HEARD A LOT OF THE
STATISTICS ARE NOT GONNA BE
GOING OVER THE STATISTICS AGAIN.
MY NAME IS DONNA BEEN TEN I'M AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO AND THE DIRECTOR OF A ONE
OF THE ELEVEN CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS A. GALLUP.
IN CALIFORNIA AND SO TODAY I'M
GONNA BE FOCUSING MY REMARKS AND
FOR ISSUES THAT ARE REALLY WHAT
I CONSIDER GAPS IN WHAT WE'VE
NOTICES GAPS IN SERVICES. FOR
FAMILY CAREGIVERS AND TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION WE HAVE ONE OUT OF
ONE OUT OF EVERY FOUR HOUSEHOLDS
HAVE FAMILY CARE GIVERS AND WILK
CERTAINLY WE ARE NOT REACHING
THAT WERE PROBABLY REACHING MORE
LIKE 122%.
OF THOSE HOUSEHOLDS WE YOU KNOW
WE OFTEN HEAR ABOUT THE NEED TO
ADDRESS DIVERSITY.
AND WHEN DEVELOPING POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA.
IN GENERAL WHEN PEOPLE THINK OF
DIVERSITY THIS DISCUSSION TENDS
TO FOCUS ON RACE AND ETHNICITY.
TODAY WHAT I WANT YOU TO DO IS
KIND OF EXPAND YOUR DEFINITION.
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FAMILY
CARE GIVING?
BECAUSE WINDOWS DIVRSITY WHAT
WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE WHEN WE
APPLY IT TO FAMILY CARE GIVERS
AND IT'S GOING TO BE MUCH
BROADER IN SCOPE.
WHEN WE ARE LOOKING AT FAMILY
CARE GIVING AND DIVERSITY? FOR
THIS POPULATION WE HAVE TO BE --
REALLY HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF DIVERSITY WHICH
INCLUDES NOT JUST RACE AND
ETHNICITY.
BUT ALSO PREFERENCES SUCH AS
CULTURAL PREFERENCES FOR FAMILY
CARE GIVERS AND HOW THEY WANT TO
BE.
PRESENTED WITH SERVICES WHERE
THEY WANT TO ACCESS SERVICES AND
WHEN THEY WANT TO ACCESS
SERVICES.
THERE CERTAINLY IS DIVERSITY
BROKE --
AMONG H..
CARE GIVERS RANGE FROM A FOR OUR
GROUP EIGHTEEN AND UP.
AND WE SEE DIFFERENT GENERATIONS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
PEOPLE TEND TO EAT FOR AND
THEY'RE ALL CARING FOR OLDER
ADULTS.
BUT IF YOU HAVE A THIRTY SIX
YEAR OLD THE WORKING.
AND CARING FOR THEIR FAMILY
MEMBER THEIR NEEDS ARE GOING TO
BE DIFFERENT THAN THE EIGHTY SIX
YEAR OLD WHO'S CARING FOR THEIR
SPOUSE.
BUT HOW DO WE GO ABOUT
UNDERSTANDING WHY HOW THEIR
SIMILAR.
AND SO ONE OF THE FIRST GAPS I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IS A NEED FOR
ACE OF GOOD STANDARDIZED
ASSESSMENT TOOL.
WHAT WE DON'T HAVE --
CONSISTENTLY EXCEPT TO LOOK ONE
A COUPLE OF SYSTEMS IS A
STANDARDIZED ASSESSMENT TOOL
THAT IT DOES A COMPREHENSIVE
ASSESSMENT FOR FAMILY CAREGIVERS.
WE NEED TO HAVE A SIMILAR LEVEL
OF LIKE THE MINIMUM DATA SET OF
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE ANOTHER
SYSTEMS.
SO THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
A PERSON'S EMPLOYMENT STATUS --
HOW DOES GENDER GENDER IDENTITY
IMPACT THEIR FAMILY CARE GIVING
OUT IS INCOME IMPACT FAMILY CARE
GIVING?
WHAT'S THE CARE RECIPIENTS AND
THE CARE RECEIVERS HEALTH STATUS.
WE'RE OFTEN ASK IS CARE GIVERS
TO ALL COULD YOU COULD GO HOME
TAKE CARE OF YOUR HUSBAND BUT
HAS ANYONE ASKED THE CARE GIVER
ABOUT THEIR BACK PROBLEMS.
THEIR SLEEPING HABITS.
THINGS LIKE THAT.
WE NEED MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
CONCERNS OF THE CARE GIVER
WHAT'S THEIR MENTAL HEALTH LIKE
AND WHAT KIND OF SOCIAL SUPPORT
DO THEY HAVE.
WHEN THEY START THEIR CARE
GIVING JOURNEY?
BECAUSE IT IS GOING TO BE QUITE
A LOT OF THE TIME THAT THEY WILL
BE PROVIDING CARE ON AVERAGE
ABOUT FOUR YEARS.
WE NEED A SYSTEM.
THROUGH THIS ASSESSMENT THAT HAS
THAT FLEXIBILITY SO THAT.
GET A LOT OF INFORMATION THAT'S
THE SAME BUT THEN THAT ALLOWS
YOU TO INDIVIDUALIZE YOUR CARE
AND TREATMENT PLANNING FOR THE
FAMILY CAREGIVER SO THE A ONE
BIG GAP IS HAVING.
CONSISTENT INFORMATION FROM OUR
CARE GIVERS THAT ACROSS ALL OF
OUR SYSTEMS.
THE OTHER THING WE WANT TO LOOK
AT I WITH THE SECOND THING IS
THE NEXT GAP IS FOR FAMILY CARE
GIVERS IS TO WAY OF IMPROVING
CARE GIVER STRESS.
THROUGH EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS.
NOW THERE OF SOME EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAMS THAT ARE OUT THERE.
THAT ARE FOR FAMILY CAREGIVERS
BUT WHAT WE FIND IS WHEN IT
COMES TO THE COMMUNITY LEVEL
THESE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
TESTED IN IDEAL SITUATIONS.
MAY NOT TRANSLATE INTO THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE THEY MAY.
REQUIRE OF THE MAY ONLY BE IN
ENGLISH.
IT MAY REQUIRE SIX OR SEVEN
TIMES TO COME TO THE PROGRAM BUT
WHO'S GOING TO PAY FOR THEM TO
TAKE A BREAK AND BE AT HOME AND
WHERE'S THE RESPITE CARE FOR
THAT --
MAYBE AND SOMETIMES THE FUNDING
DOESN'T ALLOW FOR IT THE A
AGENCIES TO ACTUALLY BE
REIMBURSED BECAUSE YOU NEED TO
TRAINERS.
AND THEY'RE SAYING WELL WE'RE
ONLY GONNA PAY FOR ONE PERSON TO
DO THE TRAINNG BUT THE MODEL
THE EVIDENCE BASED.
THAT HAS LINKED TO OUTCOMES.
REQUIRES TWO TRAINERS AT THE
SAME TIME IN THE CITY --
NO WE'RE ONLY GOING TO GIVE YOU
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS TO DO THIS
PROGRAM.
THAT'S IT.
WOULDN'T THAT IS A MAJOR GAP AND
WE NEED TO HAVE POLICIES THAT
ALLOW FOR THAT TYPE OF
FLEXIBILITY --
THE OTHER THE THIRD THING I WANT
YOU TO THINK AROUND GAPS IS I
MENTIONED EMPLOYMENT AS A TYPE
OF DIVERSITY FOR FAMILY
CAREGIVERS.
AND GET AS YOU HEARD BEFORE WE
HAVE ABOUT 60% OF CARE GIVERS
WHO WERE IN THE WORKPLACE.
BUT WHAT WE DON'T HAVE A
CONSISTENT POLICIES THAT --
ARE.
HELP PROTECT FAMILY CARE GIVERS
WE HEAR STORIES OF CARE GIVERS
WHO KNOW THAT BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TO MAYBE TAKE OFF MORE TIME
THERE'S AND JOB PROTECTION.
AND THEY ALSO SOMETIMES FEEL
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST ONE
SOMEBODY HEARS THAT THEY ARE
FAMILY CARE GIVER SO THEY DON'T
TALK ABOUT THEIR CARE GIVING --
AND WE KNOW THE CARE GIVERS ARE
READY DON'T SELF IDENTIFIED BUT
NOW THEY DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY
CAN EVEN MENTION IT TO AN
EMPLOYER.
BECAUSE THEY MAY NOT HAVE ANY
TYPE OF PROTECTION.
AND AT THE SAME TIME AS FAR AS
EMPLOYMENT.
OUR CARE GIVERS NEED TO HAVE
SOME FLEXIBILITY SO THAT.
DEPENDING ON WHEN YOU'RE WORKING
THE SUPPORT SERVICES NEED TO BE
ABLE TO BE ONLINE AND PROVIDE
SOME OF THE TRAINING AND
EDUCATION.
THAT FILTERED INDIVIDUALLY THAT
COMES OUT OF THAT GREAT
ASSESSMENT THAT YOU MAY HAVE --
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO HAVE THAT
INDIVIDUAL TIME WHEN THEY CAN DO
IT WHICH MIGHT BE IT TEN AT
NIGHT.
MIGHT BE EIGHT IN THE MORNING
BUT NOT THE NORM NOT THE NINE TO
FIVE FINALLY WE KNOW THE CARE
GIVING IS A JOURNEY.
AND BECAUSE OF THIS WE REALLY.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE SUPPORT.
FROM TIME FOR RESPITE FOR FAMILY
CAREGIVERS.
THERE IS A CRITICAL SHORTAGE OF
FUNDING FOR RESPITE.
THERE WE CERTAINLY HAVE RESTED
COMING IN THROUGH SOME OF THE
THREE E. PROGRAMS BUT IT'S YES
IT IS NOT ENOUGH THE LIST ARE
EXTREMELY LONG. FOR CARE GIVERS
WHO NEED A BREAK IF YOU COULD A
MATCH YOUR LIFE GOING.
FOR THREE FOUR OR MORE YEARS
WITHOUT EVER HAVING A VACATION.
WITHOUT EVER BEING ABLE TO TAKE
A DEEP BREATH ARE HAVE A GOOD
NIGHT'S SLEEP.
THAT'S ALL THEY'RE ASKING FOR
THEY'RE NOT ASKING FOR A FULL
TIME REPLACEMENT.
FAMILIES THEY WANT TO BE THERE
FOR THEIR FAMILY MEMBER.
BUT YOU KNOW IT WOULD BE NICE TO
BE ABLE TO GO AWAY FOR A COUPLE
OF HOURS OR SLEEP.
OVERNIGHT SOMETHING SOME TYPE OF
RESPITE.
SO WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO GIVE
THE ABILITY FOR FAMILY MEMBERS
AND THAT'S A BIG GAP.
AT THE OTHER THING IS PULSE CARE
GIVING.
WE DON'T OFTEN THINK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE CARE GIVER AFTER
THE PERSON AT THE BEEN CARING
FOR PASSES AWAY AND SO SOME OF
OUR SYSTEMS MOST OF THE END.
ON THE DAY THAT THE PERSON STOPS
BEING A CARE GIVER BUT HOSPICE
HAS A GREAT MODEL WHERE AT LEAST
YOU CAN.
CONTINUE TO TALK TO THE FAMILY
MEMBERS.
POST CARE GIVING FOR UP TO A
YEAR WITH SOME GRIEF COUNSELING
MAYBE JUST HELPING THEM
TANSITION BACK INTO.
THAT WORLD AGAIN BECAUSE THEY
HAVE BECOME SO ISOLATED --
SO I JUST I THINK THAT'S
ADMINISTAFF MY REMARKS THERE I
THINK I'VE USED UP MY FIVE
MINUTES.
AND ALLOWED PASADENA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
LISTENING.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND ESTEEMED
COMMITTEE --
FOR FOCUSING ON THIS ISSUE IT'S
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT AND SO
DELIGHTED AND HONORED TO BE HERE
WITH YOU TODAY --
I AM THE BETSY BUTLER I AM THE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING I'M ALSO THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S LAW CENTER.
AND AS A LONG DISTANCE CAREGIVER
AN ADVOCATE FOR WOMEN'S ISSUES --
INCLUDE ECONOMIC SECURITY.
THIS TOPIC RESONATES WITH ME --
QUITE PERSONALLY AND I'M GONNA
QUICKLY --
STORY ABOUT MY MY FAMILY MY
PARENTS AND MY FATHER AND HIS
BATTLE.
WITH ALZHEIMER'S BUT I MISS
START OFF BY SAYING THAT.
AT THE MOMENT THAT MY FATHER WAS
DIAGNOSED I WAS AFRAID IT WAS
GOING TO KILL MY MOTHER AS WELL
BECAUSE I KNEW CARE GIVING --
IS IS A TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THING
AND IF IT GETS WORSE --
SO I WAS VERY VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT HER HEALTH --
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
SO I WAS BORN REYES TURNS
ARGUMENT ON MY PARENTS LIVED
HERE MY MOM STILL LIVES HERE MY
MOM IS -- A
SPUNKY NINETY TWO GOING ON
SEVENTY REALLY LUCKY TO HAVE
THAT --
REALLY.
PART PROUD OF THE FACT THAT --
SHE IS SUCH A STRONG WOMAN AND
BEING IS BEING SO STRONG SHE WAS
ALWAYS VERY PRIVATE ABOUT THIS
SHE DIDN'T WANT.
TO TELL FRIENDS AND FAMILY --
SHE WHAT WAS ACTUALLY HAPPENING
IN THE HOUSEHOLD BECAUSE AGAIN --
MY FATHER PASSED AWAY THREE
WEEKS BEFORE THEIR FIFTIETH
WEDDING ANNIVERSARY SO.
SHE WAS VERY PRIVATE AND MY DAD
MY DAD WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
ALZHEIMER'S AT THE AGE OF SIXTY
SEVEN AND HAD IT FOR SEVENTEEN
YEARS.
SO MY MOTHER WAS HIS CARE GIVER
FOR FOURTEEN YEARS --
SHE SHE HE PASSED AWAY WHEN SHE
WAS EIGHTY FIVE SHE IS TOLD SHE
WAS TWO YEARS OLDER THAN HIM.
SO ALL OF THE EFFORT THAT YOU
PUT AND SHE WAS AN ACTUALLY
OLDER WOMAN THAN THAN MY FATHER --
ABOUT FIVE YEARS INTO MY
FATHER'S DIAGNOSIS MY MOTHER DID
QUIT HER JOB AND BECAME AN
UNPAID FULL TIME CARE GIVER --
WHICH MEANT THAT AGAIN MY FOR MY
MOTHER WAS A CARE GIVER ALL
THROUGH ER SEVENTIES AND INTO
THAT FIRST HALF OF HER EIGHTIES --
AND AS MUCH AS MY FATHER'S CARE.
AGREE MORE BURDENSOME AND
DEMANDING MY MOTHER AGAIN
THOUGHT VERY RESPONSIBLE FOR HIM
AND WOULD NOT GO OUTSIDE.
THE HOME FOR ANY HELP --
AS THE DISEASE PROGRESSED HE WAS
UNABLE TO DO MANY THINGS FOR
HIMSELF.
HE ALSO BEGAN TO HAVE VERY
IRREGULAR SLEEPING PATTERN
SOMEBODY'S LITERALLY BE UP FOR A
FEW MINUTES EVERY HOUR OF EVERY
DAY AND SO THAT MEANT THAT MY
MOTHER COULD NEVER HAVE TIME OUT
OF HER SIGHT.
SHE COULD NEVER LEAVE HIM ALONE --
AND THANKFULLY SHE FOUND ADULT
ADULT DAY SERVICES AND I BELIEVE
THAT WITHOUT ADULT A SERVICES MY
FATHER'S DISEASE WOULD HAVE
KILLED HER BECAUSE INITIALLY SHE
TOOK HIM --
AND TO THE DON'T THEY SERVICES
FOR ABOUT FIVE HOURS EVERY
COUPLE OF DAYS BUT BY THE END IT
WAS.
IT WAS A GOOD EIGHT HOURS FIVE
DAYS A WEEK AND OFTEN MY MOM
WOULD JUST GO HOME AND SLEEP
SOMETIME SHOULD RUN ERRANDS.
SHOULD EVEN GET CURVES AND
SHOULD DO A LITTLE WORK OUT BY
COMMENT TO SLEEP --
SHE SHE ULTIMATELY WHEN AN ON A
NUMBER OF OCCASIONS WHERE SHE
WAS IN SUCH BAD SHAPE THEY
LITERALLY SAID WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP YOUR DAD FOR A WEEK BECAUSE
THEY COULD JUST LOOK AT HER AND
KNOW THAT SHE WAS.
SHE WAS SPENT SHE WAS GONE AND
GETTING THE ISOLATION IS JUST.
EXHAUSTING --
TO SO -- I
LIVED IN LOS ANGELES DURING THIS
TIME I CAME UP AS MUCH AS I
COULD --
AGAIN MOM NOT BEING WELL HONEST
WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
HOUSEHOLD AS A FAMILY WE HAD
DECIDED IN AGREED THAT AS SOON
AS MY FATHER'S HYGIENE WENT --
BUT HE WE WOULD LOOK AT
PERMANENT.
A NURSING HOME CARE FOR HIM MY
MOM DID NOT TELL US THE TRUTH
ABOUT WHAT WAS HAPPENING FOR A
GOOD TWO YEARS SO MY FATHER WAS
HAVING MASSIVE TOILETING
PROBLEMS.
FOR QUITE SOME TIME --
HE WAS HAVING EMOTIONAL OUTBURST --
HE HE WASN'T A WALKER MEANING HE
NEVER WALKED OUT THE FRONT DOOR
AND LEFT THE HOUSE BUT WE NEVER
KNEW IF HE WAS GOING --
TO SHE CARRIED ALL THESE BURDENS
ON HER OWN --
AND AGAIN AS I SAID SHE WAS TWO
YEARS OLDER THAN THAN HE WAS --
SO MY DAD SPENT THE LAST TWO
YEARS OF HIS LIFE FOR RIFIC OF
MY FATHER'S NURSING HOME STAY
WITH THAT WE COULD DO A WHOLE
NOTHER -- A
HEARING ON THAT --
MY FATHER'S NURSING HOMES DAVIS
WAS ABSOLUTELY HORRIBLE WHICH
ADDED EVEN MORE GUILT AND
PRESSURE ON TO MY MOTHER BECAUSE
AS MUCH AS YOU WANT TO MOVE N
TO A NEW BETTER PLACE
ALZHEIMER'S PATIENTS ON MY TO BE
MOVED BUT THEN AGAIN ALSO.
SOMEBODY THESE PLACES ARE SO
SIMILAR AND THEIR LACK OF GOOD
CARE -- ALSO
THIS CARE AND IT WAS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IN TWENTY ELEVEN WAS
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH.
EVEN THOUGH MY MOTHER HAD
PURCHASED SOME FORM OF LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE DECADES BEFORE
NONE OF IT COVERED THIS --
THE IN THE ADULT DAY SERVICES
CARE ALSO NOT COVERED --
AND THIS WAS THE ONLY WAS MY
PARENTS WERE ACTUALLY ABLE TO
AFFORD IT WAS BECAUSE BETWEEN
THE TWO OF THEM THEY HAD. FOR
PENSIONS MEMBER PENSIONS PEOPLE --
ANYWAY THEY HAD FOR PENSIONS AND
AND THIS CARE IS VERY EXPENSIVE
BUT MY MY FAMIL WAS ABLE TO
COVER IT BECAUSE OF THE PENSIONS.
THEY HAD SO --
WITH THAT --
MY MOM.
WASN'T TRAINED IN ANYWAY CHAU TO
LEARN ALL THIS ON OUR OWN SHE
DISCUSSED BUT ALSO JUST WASN'T A
LOT.
THERE.
THOUGH -- I
WANNA REALLY AGAIN THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR DOING THIS AND AND
UNDERSCORE THOUGH A COUPLE
THINGS ABOUT --
ABOUT --
CARE GIVING PARTICULARLY AS IT
APPLIES TO WOMEN AND I WANNA
ALSO --
REALLY.
APPRECIATE AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR PUTTING TOGETHER
THE GREAT BACKGROUND PAPER WAS
REALLY REALLY HELPFUL IN.
AND OUR OUR REITERATE SOME OF IT
BECAUSE T IS THAT IMPORTANT SO
AS MENTIONED CARE OF IT GIVING
IS DECIDEDLY A WOMEN'S ISSUE.
60% OF CARE GIVERS ARE WOMEN THE
AVERAGE AGE OF AN INFORMAL CARE
GIVERS --
4910% OF THE CARE GIVERS ARE
SEVENTY FIVE OR OLDER 85% OF THE
CARE IS PROVIDED --
FOR A FAMILY MEMBER.
THE AVERAGE DURATION AS AND ON
HAVE MENTIONED IS FOUR YEARS --
IN A PARK APPROXIMATELY 20%
PRIDE 25% OF THE CARE GIVERS
HAVE PROVIDED CARE FOR FIVE
YEARS OR MORE --
CARE GIVING COMES AT A AT A
REALLY HUGE COSTS AS A MISTER
PEDOPHILE MENTIONED --
CARE GIVERS IS APPROXIMATELY SIX
HUNDRED IF A LIFETIME.
DUE TO LOST PAY INCREASES
REDUCED RETIREMENT CONTRIBUTIONS
LOWER SAVINGS.
LOWER SO SECURITY EARNINGS AND
REDUCED ABILITY TO MAINTAIN HOME
HOME UPKEEP --
ALSO WANNA WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT AS WOMEN SINCE WERE NEVER
PAID WHAT WERE WORTH ITS WERE
STILL.
LACKING IN THAT AND THE NEW
DYNAMIC OF OF WOMEN SUCH AS
MYSELF WHO HAVE NEVER MARRIED
AND DON'T HAVE CHILDREN --
A LOT OF WOMEN OUT THERE I I
THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF FRIENDS
WILL BE TAKING CARE OF ONE
ANOTHER BUT THAT'S ANOTHER
DYNAMIC TO THIS --
NOT HOW I DON'T HAVE A BIG
FAMILY I I DIDN'T HAVE A FAMILY
SO.
THAT'S ANOTHER --
MAJOR CONCERN AND SINGLE WOMEN
WHOCARE FOR ELDERLY PARENTS OR
TWO POINT FIVE TIMES MORE LIKELY.
A TO BE IMPOVERISHED WHEN THEY
ARE OLDER SO THE POVERTY --
KEEPS.
KEEPS GROWING AND AGAIN I JUST
WANT TO UNDERSCORE UNDERSCORE
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS THAT YOU ALL
ARE.
MAKING A DECISION I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME VERY VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
US HERE TODAY --
AND TO SHARE OUR EXPERIENCES A
ANA WITH CARE GIVING --
I'M.
I'VE CARED FOR MULTIPLE FAMILY
MEMBERS AND THROUGHOUT MY LIFE
AND I'M A VOLUNTEER WITH THE A A
RP.
BUT I'D LIKE TO SHARE MY
PERSONAL STORY AND MY NAME IS
BEVERLY I WAS ORPHANED AT A
YOUNG AGE MY FATHER WHEN I WAS
SEVEN AND MY MOM WHEN I WAS --
ELEVEN AND IN SPITE OF THE
DIFFICULTIES OF FOR CARRYING.
FOR OTHER RELATIVES.
AND PARENTS --
I HAD.
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES WITH
CARING FOR FAMILY AND
SPECIFICALLY MY GRANDMOTHER WHEN
I WAS JUST A YOUNG GIRL BECAUSE
SHE DIDN'T SPEAK ENGLISH.
BUT HER HEALTH WAS ALREADY NOT
WELL BUT SHE WOULDN'T LET
ANYBODY KNOW.
AND AS I GOT OLDER WILL I'D LIKE
TO SHARE JUST A COUPLE OF TIMES
THAT I'VE BEEN ABLE TO HELP.
MY IN LAWS --
MY FATHER WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
CANCER IN THE IN THE EIGHTIES
WHEN WE LIVED HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WERE ORIGINALLY FROM THE
MODERATE AREA MY HUSBAND AND I
SO OUR FAMILIES ARE THERE.
SO --
LOCALLY I WORK IN A HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM THAT WOULD HELP.
GET MY IN LAWS ON THEIR HIVE
PLAN.
AND DURING HIS ILLNESS ON MY
MOTHER LOVE BUT FORGET TO PAY
THE PAY PREMIUMS SO WE WOULD
COVER THE PREMIUMS.
COPAYS FOR THE PHARMACEUTICALS
THAT WOULD NEED WERE NEEDED.
ON MY HEAD HUSBAND HAD IS OFF
ALL AND HE CLOSED IT SO HE COULD
WORK OUT OF THE HOUSE.
SO THEY COULD STAY THERE DURING
THE DAY WHILE I'VE WORKED FULL
TIME -- AND
IT WASN'T A FAMILY FRIENDLY
ENVIRONMENT THERE WAS NO.
FMLA OR ANYTHING --
I HAD KIDS THAT WERE IN SCHOOLS
SO.
I WORKED FULL TIME.
I DIDN'T SHARE A LOT AT WORK.
AND CAME HOME AND PREPARED MEALS
FOR FOR THE FOR ALL OF US.
IN NATURE MY OUR KIDS GO TO
SCHOOL --
SOMETIMES IF MY MOTHER IN LAW
HAD A ISSUE WITH MY FATHER Là
SHE WOULD LIKE THE AND SEE WHAT
I COULD DO.
AND AND MY HUSBAND TO I'M NOT
GONNA SAY IT WAS ON ME BECAUSE I
WAS MORE OF A BACK UP.
ON AND THEN YOU KNOW MAKING SURE
OUR KIDS MARKET I OUR DAUGHTER
WAS A SENIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL WHEN
HE WAS.
ACTUALLY TERMINAL AND AND
HOSPICE.
AND SO THAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
YOUR FINE YEAR BUT IT WAS.
THERE WAS --
HE PASSED AWAY RIGHT BEFORE HER
GRADUATION BUT WE MADE THE BEST
OF IT AND TRY TO KEEP OUR SON
BUSY -- TO
SO WE WERE REALLY DO WHAT IT WAS
LIKE OF OUR CULTURE DOESN'T PUT
OUR FOR FAMILY MEMBERS AND HOMES.
I WOULDN'T HAVE A CLUE UNTIL
LATELY ASKING PEOPLE HOW MUCH IT
COSTS AND HOW IT WAS.
MORE I WAS SHOCKED.
BECAUSE WE TAKE CARE OF OUR OWN
THAT'S A WE WERE RATIONING
GRANDMOTHER TOOK CARE OF ALL OF
US.
AND SO IN THE RECENT YEARS --
ACTUALLY AFTER MY FATHER Là
PASSED AWAY --
AND I WAS WORKING --
ACTUALLY I WAS IN HEALTH CARE
WITH MY HUSBAND FATHER IN LAW.
WENT AND THEN I RETIRED AND WENT
TO VOLUNTEERING GOT HIRED AT THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY.
AND THEN MY MOTHER IN LAW WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH ALZHEIMER'S.
SO SHE WOULD COME FROM MODERATE
TO HEAR TO GET HER HEALTH CARE
AND SEE HER DOCTORS OR TO GILROY.
AND STAY WITH US AND THEN SHE'D
GO HOME THE SO WE WERE PREPARED
TO TAKE HER AND AND FORGETTING
TO PAY THINGS SO WE WERE PAYING
FOR HER PREMIUMS AND TRYING TO
KEEP OUR HOME GOING.
WELL MY HUSBAND WAS SELF
EMPLOYED.
AND HERE PROVIDING
TRANSPORTATION FOOD AND THE
FAMILY WOULD COME TO SEE BOTH OF
THEM AT DIFFERENT TIMES AND SO
WE WERE HOUSING PEOPLE AND
FEEDING.
AND THEN MOST RECENTLY ONE OF MY
FRIENDS WHO WAS MARRIED BUT
NEVER HAD CHILDREN --
HER HOW HER HEALTH WAS FAILING
AND A SHE'S BEEN REALLY INVOLVED
IN ALL OF THESE COMMUNITY
SLIGHTLY --
AND HER HUSBAND.
WAS HER CARE GIVER THAN HE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH LUNG CANCER.
AND HER HE INJURED HIMSELF
CARING FOR HER SO I WAS TAKING
HIM TO THE DOCTOR AND EMERGENCY
ROOMS AND HOSPITAL VISITS
BECAUSE HE THERE HE WAS IN THE
HOSPITAL OR SHE WAS IN THE
HOSPITAL HERE.
AND HE DIDN'T LAST TO MONTHS AND
SO NOW SHE'S DEPRESSED.
HE CAN'T TAKE CARE OF HERSELF HE
WAS HER CARE GIVER SO I WAS
TRYING.
TO PROVIDE TRANSPORTATION TO HER
AND SOMETIMES BUYING FOOD FOR
THE BOTH OF THEM AND THEN HER
ALONE.
AND THE PICKING UP THE
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR THEM ON FOR
HER -- SO IT
WAS -- IT
WAS A IT HAD TO HAPPEN SHE
DIDN'T HAVE FAMILY HERE.
SO I'VE I'VE TRIED TO DO WHAT I
CAN TO HELP THEM AND YOU KNOW
THE HOURS INVOLVED I'M RETIRED.
AGAIN.
ANNAI HAVE FAMILY AND I HAVE MY
GRANDKIDS I TOLD MY KIDS AT ON
THE GRAND KIDS WOULD BE THE
PRIORITY SINCE I WORKED ALL.
ALL THEIR LIVES AND I HAD NO
PARENTS TO HELP ME.
A LIVING IN SACRAMENTO AND NO
FAMILY.
SO THEY WERE EITHER DAYCARE OR
SCHOOL OR WHATEVER WE HAD TO DO --
AND I WANT --
TO THANK YOU FOR THE AT THE
ISSUE YOU BROUGHT UP BECAUSE I'M
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED AND HEALTH
CARE AND I'VE BEEN PUSHING
TOWARD CULTURALLY COMPETENT --
ISSUES DRESS ADDRESSING PEOPLE
WHO HAVE.
HEALTH ISSUES BECAUSE MOST OF
OUR CULTURES DON'T COME OUT AND
ASK WHAT CAN YOU DO FOR ME.
THEY DON'T I MEAN I DIDN'T HAVE
A CLUE ABOUT ANY OF THE SERVICES
THAT HAPPEN.
WE MAY NOT HAVE QUALIFIED I
DON'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT.
NOTHING WAS OFFERED.
pI HAD NO IDEA.
AN HOUR WHEN I WAS AT THE
AMERICAN CANCER THEIR WORK WITH
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES AND SO AS
DIFFERENT AS WE ARE WERE VERY
SIMILAR --
YOU KNOW JUST BEING
UNDERSTANDING OF WE DO TAKE CARE
OF OUR OWN WE DO THE BEST WE CAN
AND WE DON'T.
TELL EVERYBODY AND I WAS SHOCKED
WHEN THEY ASKED ME TO TALK OF
HUNT THIS BECAUSE I'D I DIDN'T
REALLY TALK ABOUT IT TO
EVERYBODY --
I WORK FULL TIME I WORKED ALL MY
LIFE AND WE USED TO A LOT OF OUR
MONEY TO HELP CARE FOR OUR LOVED
ONES.
ARE TRIED TO HELP MY FRIENDS
WHEN THEY CAN THAT A LOT OF
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT I TRIED TO
GO ON HEALTH.
I'D TAKE A VACATION WEEK TO GO.
EITHER TO MONTEREY OR WHATEVER
TO SEE WHAT I COULD DO TO
RELIEVE EITHER MY BROTHER OR MY
COUSIN.
WITH THE HEALTH OF THEIR SPOUSE
OR FAMILY MEMBER.
I YOU KNOW ALL OF THE ISSUES I
WAS GOING TO BRING UP WERE
PRETTY MUCH ADDRESSED AN
INCREASE IN PREMIUMS FOR
INSURANCE COPAYS.
THE PRESCRIPTIONS ARE OUT OF OUT
OF THIS WORLD I CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
THE FAMILIES ARE LIVING FURTHER
APART AND WITH FEWER CHILDREN
ARE NOT CHILDREN.
THE COST OF EVERYTHING HAS RISEN
NOT JUST HEALTH FOOD UTILITIES I
MEAN JUST BUYING.
IT SACRAMENTO RENTING A PLACE OF
HOUSING IS OFTEN ON AFFORDABLE
FOR PEOPLE.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO WORKED ALL
THEIR LIVES DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
TO FALL BACK ON THE RECESSION
WIPED OUT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
AND YOU DON'T.
YOU MAKE MORE THAN WHAT YOU.
WHAT QUALIFIES YOU FOR ANY
ASSISTANT BUT NOT ENOUGH TO BE
SUSTAINABLE AND TO HAVE A
HEALTHY LIFE OR TO HAVE SOMEBODY
COME IN AND HELP YOU?
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T.
YOU JUST CAN'T AFFORD IT --
IN -- ONE OF
THE LATEST THINGS THAT I'M
FINDING.
MOST EMPLOYERS ARE HIRING PART
TIME PEOPLE WITH NO BENEFITS.
SO NOT ONLY DO YOU NOT WANT TO
SAY ANYTHING AT WORK BUT YOU
DON'T HAVE YOUR BENEFITS THAT
YOU CAN TAKE FMLA THAT YOU CAN
TAKE VACATION OR SICK LEAVE
YOU'RE NOT THERE YOU DON'T GET
PAID.
THAT IS A HUGE ISSUE WITH SOME
OF THESE.
AND I'M BRINGING IT UP BECAUSE I
HAVE FAMILY FRIENDS AND PEOPLE
THAT I WORKED WITH.
THAT ARE TAKING CURRENTLY TAKING
CARE OF THEIR LOVED ONES.
THAT ARE SOMETIMES IN THE SAME
SITUATION.
I KNOW YOU CAN'T GUARANTEE
EVERYTHING.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME SOMETHING
NEEDS TO BE DONE.
ALL RIGHT NOW.
I'M A LITTLE UNFOCUSED BECAUSE
WE'RE MOVING INTO A TOMORROW OR
THURSDAY.
AREN'T MY HUSBAND MY SON BOUGHT
A HOME AND IT HAS AN IN LAW UNIT
BECAUSE WE WILL OUR SON IN LAW.
OUR SON AND DAUGHTER IN LAW WERE
WE'VE HAD A COMBINED HOME FOR
THE PAST MAYBE TEN YEARS.
I HELP WITH THE GRAND KIDS HE
HAD A HOME BUSINESS AND HE'S
WORKING.
AND THEN MY HUSBAND STILL
WORKING HE NEEDS TO RETIRE.
BUT THAT'S WHERE I'M COMING FROM
WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF A MOVE SO.
HOPEFULLY MADE SENSE.
THE CHAIR AND THE OTHER SENATORS
HERE TODAY FAIR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS YOU ON BEHALF OF
FAMILY CARE GIVERS OF THE OVER
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH
ALZHEIMER'S AND OTHER DEMENTIAS.
NAME IS BARBARA MARQUEZ AND I
CURRENTLY SERVE AS A BOARD
MEMBER FOR THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION CHAPTER.
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO SHARE SOME
OF THE EXPERIENCES OF MY JOURNEY.
AS A CARE GIVER FOR MY MOM
FLORENCE MARQUEZ.
BUT I'D LIKE TO JUST IF YOU
WOULD INDULGE ME JUST REMEMBER I
LIKE TO TELL YOU ABOUT MY MOM
FOR JUST A MINUTE. TO HONOR HER.
SHE WAS BORN IN TEXAS BUT REYES
FROM THE AGE OF SEVEN IN THE
DEREK HOUGH CALIFORNIA.
SHE WAS ONE OF THE TIME TEN
SIBLINGS AND FARMWORKERS FAMILY
THAT WORKED.
VARIOUS CROPS THROUGHOUT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
JOE IS A VERY PROUD OF THE FACT
THAT SHE CONTRIBUTED TO FEEDING
AMERICA.
AFTER SHE MARRIED MY DAD AND MY
KIDS IN NINETEEN FIFTY THREE
DAVID D. SAN JOSE.
WITH ABOUT A SMALL HOUSE IN HIS
THEIR FAMILY.
SHE WAS A VERY ACTIVE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING DVOCATE FOR THE
LARGELY HISPANIC COMMUNITY
LIVING IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
JAIL MANY NON PROFIT DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATION THE BILL TO THIRTY
FIVE UNIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COMPLEX ON SANTEE SAN ANTONIO
ACROSS THE STREET FROM MY LADY
WHAT A LOSER.
IN AREA ONCE CALLED FILL
SEQUENCES IT'S THE SAME AREA
RECESS OR TRAVIS BEGAN HIS
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING IN THE LATE
NINETEEN FIFTIES.
SHE AND MY DAD SUPPORT
ACCESSORIES WORK THROUGHOUT THE
YEARS AND OFTEN SPENT TIME WITH
HIM ON THE PICKET LINES.
IN HONOR FOR MANY YEARS A
CLEANING SERVICE SHE WAS IN THIS
VERY SAME BUILDING.
ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AGO AND SHE
RECEIVED THIS WONDERFUL WORK
FROM ONE OF YOUR PREDECESSORS.
LEGISLATOR OF THE YEAR AWARD --
THE LATE STATE SENATOR JOHN
VASCONCELOS.
IT WAS A PROUD MOMENT.
FEEL PROBABLY.
AND SHE'S THE PROUD CALIFORNIANS.
ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO OR SO MY
MOTHER RECEIVED A DIAGNOSIS OF
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE.
IT WAS DEVASTATING IS.
THAT WE ALL BEGAN TO BEAT ABOUT
THE DISEASE WE LEARNED A LOT BUT
A REALITY WE HAD NO IDEA THAT
WE'D BE FACING.
ABOUT FIVE YEARS INTO THE
DIAGNOSIS IT BECAME QUITE
APPARENT TO THE FAMILY THAT SHE
COULD NO LONGER LIVE ALONE.
IT WAS DECIDED IT WAS BEST FOR
HER TO SACRAMENTO TO LIVE WITH
ME AND MY HUSBAND.
WE ARE EMPTY NESTERS AT THE TIME
MY CHILDREN COLLEGE.
ALTHOUGH I WAS STILL WORKING
FULL TIME.
HER HEALTH AND SAFETY BECAME MY
PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY.
A TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TELL US FOR
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
THAT MUCH TO SHARE ABOUT THIS
JOURNEY BUT I'M GOING TO FOCUS
ON THREE MAJOR ASPECTS.
THE STRUGGLE TO GET THE
NECESSARY IF NECESSARY
INDICATION TRAINING TO TAKE ON
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF CARE
GIVING FOR ANOTHER ADULT.
THE FINANCIAL COSTS IN THE
EMOTIONAL TURMOIL.
SO WHEN I GO CREE TO TAKE ON
THIS ROLE RECALL THAT IT DIDN'T
SEEM ALL HAVE DONE I FAILED TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THAT MY
MOTHER'S CONDITION WAS NOT
STATIC.
IT WOULD DRIVE ME OUT THE CHECK
DIGIT DRASTICALLY CHANGE OVER
THE COMING WEEKS MONTHS AND
YEARS.
WORKING MY MOTHER TO THE HOUSE
HELD WAS SO DIFFERENT FROM THE
DELIBERATE STEPS THAT WE TOOK
WHEN HE BROUGHT NEW ADDITIONS TO
OUR FAMILY IN THE FORM OF OUR
CHILDREN.
AT THAT TIME.
A BE HANDLED WITH A THERE ISN'T
IT GUIDANCE ABANDONED EDUCATION
AND TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES IN
THE FORM PRENATAL CLASSES
PARENTING CLASSES.
BOOK FILLED LIBRARY SHELVES.
THERE IS ONLINE RESOURCES AND
THE LIST WENT ON THERE'S ALSO
TYPICALLY A LOT FOR ABUNDANT
RESOURCE ADVICE AND SUPPORT FROM
FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
THEY WOULD TURN INTO US IN
TELESERYES OF AND THEY ALSO
OFFER CHILDCARE FOOD OTHER
SUPPORTIVE WORDS AND ACTIONS.
NOTHING LIKE THAT HAPPENED WHEN
MOM CAME TO LIVE WITH US.
PLAYING FIELD IT FIRSTHAND THE
COLD REALITY OF THE STIGMA
ASSOCIATED WITH DIMENSION AGING
THAT EXIST IN OUR SOCIETY AND
CULTURE.
IT'S SILENT.
YET IT STILL MANY QUESTIONS WITH
NEW ISSUES CROPPING UP
CONSTANTLY I SEARCHED HIGH AND
LOW FOR RESOURCES.
WOULD I TURN TO FOR ADVICE AND
GUIDANCE.
SOCIALLY ADDRESS MANY CHANGES IN
HER BEHAVIOR HOW CAN I BETTER
COMMUNICATE WITH HER.
OKAY GREAT HANDOVER GROWING
NEEDS FOR ASSISTANCE WITH
GROOMING AND BATHING TOILETING
AND OTHER HYGIENE ISSUES OKAY
SAFELY TRANSFER.
TRANSFER FROM BED TO WHEEL CHAIR
WITHOUT CAUSING HER TO FULLER
FOR INJURING MYSELF.
I FELT THAT THESE TRAINING
EDUCATION NEEDS JUST INCREASED
OVER TIME TO MATCH THE
PROGRESSIVE MANIFESTATIONS OF
THE DISEASE BOTH PHYSICALLY AND
BEHAVE REALLY.
IT WAS A MOVING TARGET.
I VENTURE STARTED TEN IN SOME
INDICATION CLASSES OFFERED
THROUGH THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION.
I WAS FORTUNATE BECAUSE THE
CLASSES ARE OFFERED CLOSE BY.
HE SAYS SESSIONS MADE QUITE A
DIFFERENT.
HOWEVER I MEAN WE START TO
WONDER WHAT OTHER CARE GIVERS DO
SPECIALLY THOSE WHO LIVE IN MORE
REMOTE PARTS OF THE STATE.
OR WHOSE PRIMARY LANGUAGE IS AN
ENGLISH HOW DO THESE.
TAXES THIS CENTRAL INFORMATION.
I QUESTION HOW COME THERE'S NOT
THE START THE CLASSES WERE
ORIGINALLY OFFERED AT THE
LIBRARIES IN OUR OWN COMMUNITIES
AT THE CHURCH AS THE MEDICAL
OFFICES.
AND OTHER COMMUNITY VENUE
ECONOMIC COST I WAS WORKING FULL
TIME WHEN MY MOTHER CAME TO LIVE
WITH US.
AND I NEEDED TO CONTINUE TO DO
SO HELP COVER THE COST OF OUR
CHILDREN'S COLLEGE TUITION AND
OTHER EDUCATIONAL COST.
IN ADDITION TO ADDRESSING MOMS
LIVING EXPENSES.
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE WORKING I
SECURED A SPOT FOR MOM IN AN
ADULT DAY MEMORY CARE PROGRAM IT
WAS A LIFE SAVER.
I WAS ABLE TO CONTINUE WORKING
AND IT ALSO PRIDE IN PROVIDING
ME WITH NEEDED RESPITE TIME.
IN ADDITION IT SERVES AN
IMPORTANT SOURCE OR
SOCIALIZATION FOR MY MOM.
SHE LOVED HER COFFEE IN CHIEF
FIDDLE OF IT THERE.
THE DELTA A MEMORY KERR PROGRAMS
DEFINITELY SHOULD BE VIEWED AS A
VALUABLE AN ESSENTIAL COMMUNITY
SERVICE JUST LIKE SO MANY OTHER
CENTRALSERVICES.
THAT WE SUPPORT WHEN THAT OFFERS
CULTURALLY COMPETENT SERVICES TO
BEST MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
SADLY WEDNESDAY WE WERE INFORMED
THAT ARE ADULT A MEMORY KERR
PROGRAM WHICH TO BE CLOSED
ROUGHLY.
IT LEFT ME IN THE OTHER FAMILIES
IN A PANIC AND WITH MORE
QUESTIONS.
WHAT OTHER?
THE DEL MEMORY CARE PROGRAMS.
ARE AVAILABLE CLOSE BY HOW
LONGER THERE WAITING LIST WHAT
ARE THE COST WOULD I BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE WORK.
ULTIMATELY THE DECISIONWAS MADE
THAT I NEEDED TO RETIRE EARLY.
MY EARLY RETIREMENT HAS VERY
ADVERSELY IMPACTED THE LEVEL MY
PENSION.
AS FORTUNATE TO HAVE A GOOD
STEAK CREATOR.
WHICH I RECEIVED WHICH IN THIS
LOWER AMOUNT WILL IS THE ABOUT
OUR SEE THE REST OF MY LIFE.
WITH REDUCED MONTHLY EARNINGS
ARE HOUSEHOLD INCOME WAS FURTHER
IMPACTED BY THE COST OF SUPPLIES
MEDICATIONS.
AND OTHER ITEMS DATED BY MY MOM.
AT TAX TIME I WOULD WONDER.
WHY WE COULDN'T TAKE A TAX
DEDUCTION FOR CARRYING
SUPPORTING MY MY KNOWLEDGE?
EVENTUALLY WHEN I CAN NO LONGER
TRANSFER MY MOM.
FROM HER WHEELCHAIR.
TO THE TOILET OR TO HER BED.
AND ENSURE HER SAFETY IN OUR
HOME WE HAD EXPLORED RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES.
THE MONTHLY COST WAS EXORBITANT
AND AGAIN RAISE SO MANY MORE
QUESTIONS FOR ME.
MY MOTHER HAD WORKED ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT WHERE
WERE THE AFFORDABLE AFFORDABLE
CARE MODELS THAT WOULD.
VIED FOR SENIORS WHO NEEDED CARE.
AND IF THERE WERE SEVEN OTHER
STATES WHY CAN THEY BE
REPLICATED HERE.
I THOUGHT OFTEN ABOUT THE
COOPERATIVE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAD --
WHEN THE CHILDREN WERE IN
CHILDCARE?
CAN SOMETHING BE PILOTED SO THAT
RESIDENTIAL CARE COULD BE MORE
AFFORDABLE.
THAT FAMILY MEMBERS COULD WORK
IN A COMMUNITY AND PROVIDE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT OPTIONS FOR
DIVERSE POPULATIONS.
LESLIE THE TOLL OF PROVIDING
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN CARE IS
EXTREMELY STRESSFUL AS NOTED BY
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS AND
EMOTIONALLY EXHAUSTING.
THE ISOLATION IS ALSO
DEVASTATING.
I INFREQUENTLY SO FRIENDS AND
FAMILY.
BUT I DID SEE MY DOCTOR WITH
GREATER FREQUENCY IS THE
EMOTIONAL STRESS TAKEN A
TREMENDOUS TOLL ON MY HEALTH AND
GENERAL WELL BEING.
IT WAS A HARD TIME.
I STRUGGLED WITH THE
OVERWHELMING FEELINGS OF SHAME
AND GUILT FOR NOT BEING ABLE TO
DO IT ALL FOR MY MOM.
MY MOM DIED LAST YEAR.
WHICH IS THE ABOUT THE POST.
I AM SO THANKFUL THAT WAS IT
WILL SERVICE THE CARE GIVER.
I DO ADMIT IS AN I DO MEAN IT
WAS THE HARDEST JOB I EVER HAD
BUT IT'S ALSO MY GREATEST HONOR.
SO I'M STILL PLEASE THANK YOU.
CAN PLEASE THAT THIS COMMITTEE
IS TAKE A SERIOUS LOOK AT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE FINAL
REPORT ISSUED BY.
THE CALIFORNIA TASK FORCE ON
FAMILY CARE GIVING.
MILLIONS OF AND HOW WE SHOULD
TREAT OR CENTERS.
THEY SHOULD HAVE A VIABLE
ACCESSIBLE CULTURALLY COMPETENT
OPTIONS. FOR RESPITE SERVICES.
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
INAPPROPRIATE TRAINING EDUCATION
RESOURCES TO ASSIST AND HELP
THEM WITH THEIR DAILY TASKS.
THESE TRAINING SEEM TO BE
ACTIVELY ACCESSIBLE
GEOGRAPHICALLY OFFERED AT LOWER
NO COST AND MADE AVAILABLE IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES. ONE OF THE
ALL OF YOU AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO THINK SENATOR.
JACKSON FOR CO AUTHORING.
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT I
THINK THAT --
I'M OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL RETIRED.
I THINK WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
BEGIN COMMUNITIES WE NEED TO BE
WORKING WITH COMMUNITIES HEARING
THEIR INPUT AND THEIR
SUGGESTIONS IN THEIR IDEAS.
DIRECTLY SO THAT WE CAN.
DEVELOP APPROPRIATE STRATEGIES
TO ADDRESS THEM --
THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE FOR THOSE
LIVING IN THAT COMMUNITY.
PLEASE DO CONSIDER AND TAKE THE
NEEDED ACTION. TO PROVIDE THE
REQUIRED RESOURCES TO ASSIST
FAMILY CARE GIVERS AND IN DOING
SO YOU'LL ALSO LEE ALSO APPROVED
REALLY BE HONORING.
OUR DIVERSE SENIOR POPULATION IN
THE STATE HAVE DONE SO MUCH TO
BUILD THIS WONDERFUL GOLDEN
STATE THAT WE ALL LIVE IN TODAY.
AND I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
FOR MONEY [inaudible]
TO OF THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY AND FOR
SHARING YOUR PERSONAL STORY --
THE COMMITMENT YOU'VE SHOWN TO
TO YOUR LOVED ONES IS.
QUITE TOUCHING AND FOR ME IT DID.
PERSONAL TOUCHES MY HEART DADDY
HAVE.
SIMILAR STORY WITH THE FIELD.
GROWING UP IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND IT WOULD TAKE CARE OF OUR
OWN SO.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT.
I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS --
BUT I'D LIKE TO OPEN IT UP TO
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS. FOR
QUESTIONS FIRST I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL AGAIN ALL --
MANY OF US.
HAVE EARLY SEVENTIES SO WE DID
NOT GO THROUGH THIS RECORDS SO
IT WAS AN EXTRA TEN YEARS THAT I
DIDN'T HAVE WITH THEM.
AND SOMETIMES YOU WONDER WHAT'S
THE WHAT'S THE BETTER OPTION AND
OF COURSE --
WE ARE AGING WE ARE LIVING
LONGER HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
SEEING MORE PEOPLE DEVELOPING --
ALL SORTS OF A COGNITIVE ISSUES
AS WELL AS PHYSICAL ISSUES OF
DOING A BILL THIS YEAR JUST TO
ALLOW.
PEOPLE WHO OTHERWISE CAN'T
AFFORD TO BE ABLE TO PUT
SOMETHING SECOND GRAB BAR IN THE
BATHROOM BECAUSE WE KNOW SO I
MEAN.
THEY'RE SIMPLE THINGS LIKE THAT.
OF THEY'RE NOT BUT THEY'RE NOT
SIMPLE BECAUSE WE HAD A IF THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN IN OUR
CONSCIOUSNESS SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL.
FOR SHARING YOUR STORIES BECAUSE
I THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE OF BOTH FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVEN'T HAD THAT EXPERIENCE AND
PEOPLE HAVE AND HAVE NOT CHOP
THE TALKED ABOUT IT AND REALLY
DO NEED. TO TO TALK ABOUT IT --
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T THAT OUR
SENIORS ARE SORT OF HAVE NOT
BEEN.
ANYWHERE NEAR ON THE FRONT
BURNER BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS NOW
A NEGATIVE BIRTH RATE STATE AND
WE'RE REACHING QUITE RAPIDLY.
AND LIVING LONGER.
THAT BEING SAID --
AND I AM DOING THE BILL ON THE
MASTER PLAN AND I AND YOU KNOW
IT'S AN ENORMOUS I'M NOT QUITE
SURE WHERE TO BEGIN WITH THIS
BECAUSE YOU'VE LISTED A VARIETY
OF AREAS AND I JUST WAS TRYING
TO TAKE THEM DOWN JUST ON ON
HEALTH CARE AND LONG TERM.
CARE ALONE THERE'S A PROBLEM
WITH NURSING HOMES PAID FAMILY
LEAVE SOMETHING NEAR AND DEAR TO
MY HEART I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THAT ISSUE QUITE SOME TIME.
ADULT DAY CARE HOW IMPORTANT
THAT IS TO GIVE RESPITE CARE TO
THE TO THE PROVIDER --
TO AND AS YOU MENTIONED A LOT OF
FAMILY MEMBERS ARE NOT KIDS THEY
ARE OFTEN TIMES SENIORS
THEMSELVES OR FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
HAVE BEEN WORKING AND HAVE TO
DIVIDE TO GET.
TO YOU KNOW CAN I CONTINUE TO
WORK HOW DO I CARE FOR PEOPLE I
LOVE -- AN
IN HOME CARE SERVICES
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICES ARE
PRICES YOU MENTIONED HOW DO WE
DO WITH THE MENTION HOW DO WE
EDUCATE PEOPLE I MEAN.
THIS LIST GOES ON AND ON SO I
WANT.
WHETHER YOU HAVE BOX ON HOW WE
CAN GOING FORWARD TO MEET THESE
NEEDS IN LIGHT OF OUR CURRENT
WORK FORCE.
BY ISSUES WE ARE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE PROVIDING
THAT CARE THEMSELVES A BECAUSE I
CAN'T AFFORD. TO HAVE PEOPLE
COME INTO THE HOME --
HOW DO WE DEAL WITH EDUCATING
PEOPLE HOW DO WE MAKE --
PROVIDING THESE PROGRAMS MORE
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE WHETHER
THEY'RE CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE
OR CHOOSE THEIR SO THAT --
PEOPLE ARE WELL CARED --
FOR FOR OUR BETTER CARED FOR I
SHOULD SAY THAN THEY ARE WITH
THE SOME OF THE OPTIONS OF YOU
KNOW NURSING HOMES WHICH WE KNOW
HAVE BEEN.
JUST LACKING IN THE STATE AND
PROBABLY THE COUNTRY IN GENERAL
SO -- WHAT
WHAT DO YOU?
THINK WE SHOULD BE DOING TO GET
MORE CARE GIVERS INTO THE
PROCESS --
WHAT -- TO
HOW CAN WE GO ABOUT DEVELOPING
CARE PROVIDERS --
DO YOU HAVE ANY --
ANY SOLUTIONS OR ANY SUGGESTIONS
THAT WE MIGHT TAKE WITH US
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY YOUR STORIES
ARE BOTH VERY INTIMATE AND BOTH
VERY COMMON FOR OTHERS.
PROVIDING THAT KIND OF CARE THAT
THAT THE CHALLENGES YOU HAVE TO
GO THROUGH DECIDING.
WHO'S GOING TO TAKE CARE OF WHO
WIN AND AND HOW DO I WORKING
CONTINUE TO GET LONG DISTANCE
CARE FOR A PARENT AND HAVING
THAT THE PROBLEMS ARE REALLY.
EXTRAORDINARY AND VERY VERY
DIFFICULT SO I'M I'M SURE YOU'VE
HAD SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT IT AND
IF WITH THE INDULGENCE OF THE
CHAIR WE COULD WE COULD WE HEAR
WHAT SOME OF THOSE THOUGHTS ARE.
MORE THAN MINE IS. ONE OF MY
SUGGESTIONS IS --
HAVING.
SKEWS ME --
COMPENSATING PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRAINED TO DO PROVIDE THIS
RESPITE CARE.
SO THAT.
THEY CAN DO IT AND AND COME IN
AND NOT.
BECAUSE I KNOW MY MY COUSIN WHO
TOOK CARE OF MY AUNT SHE WAS
WORKING DOING STUFF LIKE THIS
AND THEN SHE HAD TO LEAVE HER
JOB BECAUSE IT WAS PART TIME NO
BENEFITS.
AND SHE WAS DOING WHAT SHE COULD
BUT YET THERE WAS NO
COMPENSATION WE DIDN'T KNOW HOW
YOU I DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW YOU
QUALIFY THAT'S MY THING.
THERE'S SO MANY.
SO MANY.
BARRIERS SING THIS I CHECKED
INTO DAY DAY CARE FOR MY MOTHER
IN LAW WHEN WHEN SHE WAS HERE.
I HAD NO CLUE I WILL THEY TELL
ME HOW MUCH IT WAS COSTING AND I
WENT OH MY GOODNESS I CAN'T DO
THAT.
WE'RE COVERING HOUSE PAYMENT AND
FOOD AND TAKING CARE OF HER BUT
YET.
THERE'S IS BIG AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT SHE DIDN'T HAVE.
BUT NOBODY OFFERED. TO TELL ME
WHERE I COULD GO TO SEE IF I
QUALIFY UNDER OR IF WE DID I I
DON'T SEE THAT IN THE SOCIAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENTS IN SOME OF
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS.
TRYING TO HELP.
THE MANEUVER THE SYSTEM BECAUSE
YOU KNOW YOU'RE HERE YOU GO HOME.
AND NOT I COME FROM HEALTH CARE
TO MART MORE IN THE
ADMINISTRATOR FOR HEALTH
EDUCATION PART.
SO I'M I'VE WORKED WITH PEOPLE
FOR A LONG TIME AND I'VE SEEN A
LOT OF THESE BARRIERS.
I JUST LIKE TO ADD JUST. NINE NO
LONGER WORK REPRESENT
ORGANIZATION BUT BUT I DO THINK
WE NEED TO LOOK AT FAMILY CARE
GIVERS AS A WORK FORCE.
CAN BE TREATED AND GIVEN THE
RIGHT SERVE.
OF WORKERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND UNSEEN WE SHOULD GET
TRAINING WE SHOULD GET IT.
RESPITE CARE IS WE HAVE SICK
LEAVE AND OTHER BENEFITS TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE EMPLOYED.
WHERE A VIABLE?
ENTITIES IN THE COMMUNITY WE
KEEP THE STATE RUNNING AND NOT
GOING PRO.
AND WE SHOULD BE TREATED WITH ON
THAT RESPECT IN GIVEN THOSE
CONSIDERATIONS I'M NOT SURE
EXACTLY BECAUSE I HAVEN'T REALLY
THOUGHT ABOUT ALL THOSE
CONSIDERATIONS.
BUT ALL OF YOU DO ON A DAILY
BASIS AND YOU KNOW.
AND I KNOW THAT THE PREVIOUS
PANEL TALKED ABOUT THE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS WE REPRESENT AND
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF OURS
THAT WE REPRESENT ALL UNPAID --
YOU KNOW I THINK IN THIS SOCIETY
WE USED TO YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW LET CHILDREN WORK
BEFORE SIXTEEN OR FIFTEEN THE
THINK THE TIME HAS COME FOR US
TO REALLY BE AT THE CALL ABOUT
THIS. TO GIVE IT CONSIDERATION.
TO KNOW THAT YOU KNOW PEOPLE
CAN'T TO THIS. FOR FOR YEARS AND
YEARS WITHOUT IT TAKING A
PHYSICAL TOLL.
PRESS THE CARE TO ME WHEN I TOOK
MY MOM.
TO THE DAY PROGRAM I WOULD GET A
HUG FROM SOMEBODY IN A DAILY.
IT SAY IT'S GONNA BE OKAY AND
NOBODY ELSE OFFERED HUGS.
BUT I THINK THAT IT IS IMPORTANT
TO HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE WAY OF
BRINGING CARE GIVERS LETTING
THEM KNOW WHO THEY ARE BECAUSE
CARE GIVERS DON'T SELF IDENTIFY.
SO WE DO HAVE TO HAVE A
COMBINATION BETWEEN THE CURRENT
SOCIAL SUPPORT SYSTEMS LIKE THE
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS AT
HEALTHCARE ORGANIZATIONS WHO
IDENTIFIED THE CARE GIVERS.
SO THAT THERE'S A STRONGER OF
DISCUSSION KIND OF REFERRAL
SYSTEM BETWEEN THOSE --
TWO AS BECAUSE THERE ARE SYSTEMS
OUT THERE OF COURSE ARE THE CARE
TO RESEARCH CENTERS.
BIASED BUT THEY DO NEED FUNDING
BECAUSE OF THE THEY COULD BE OUT
IN THE COMMUNITY PROVIDING ALL
THE EDUCATION TRAINING ALL OF
THAT THAT IS FUNDED BUT WE
CERTAINLY NEED AN INFUSION.
OF FUNDS THAT ALLOW FOR US TO
DELIVER IN MULTIPLE COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND IT MAY CULTURALLY SENSITIVE
WAYS I'D RESPITE BECAUSE WITH
CARE GIVERS COME IN THEY DON'T
WANT THE FRAGMENTATION.
I THINK THAT IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUES WE HAVE IS
FRAGMENTATION SO WHEN THEY CAN
GO TO WHAT I CALL ONE STOP
SHOPPING CENTERS.
AND SOMEBODY TALKS TO THEM
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY NEED NO ONE CALLS AND SAYS
I'M A CARE GIVER I NEED SERVICES.
THEY CALLAND SAY MY MOM IS
HAVING TROUBLE AND CAN YOU HELP
ME AND THEN YOU HAVE TO HAVE
SOMEONE ON THE OTHER IN WHO
UNDERSTANDS HOW TO SAY.
LET'S DISCUSS YOUR MOM BUT LET'S
ALSO TALK ABOUT YOU.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO ADD I MEAN
THERE'S THERE'S SO MUCH TO DO --
IN THIS TOPIC AND IT'S T'S HARD
TO DELINEATE WHAT SHOULD COME
FIRST AND WHAT THE TIMING IS AND
THAT THERE'S JUST SO MUCH BUT
I'LL BUT I ALSO WANT TO ADD TO
IT.
AND I'M I'M FIGURE THAT ONE OUT
BUT I ALSO WANT TO ADD TO THE
MIX THAT THIS THIS REALLY DOES
DESERVE AN INVESTMENT IN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM --
DOING GERIATRICS OR CARE GIVING
RELATED --
SCHOOLING AND EDUCATION IS IS AN
EMPLOYMENT --
SATISFACTION OFF OFF THE RAILS I
MEAN IT'S COMING WE DON'T DO
ENOUGH OF IT I KNOW THAT --
IF WE OFFERED MORE GERONTOLOGY
CLASSES IF WE OFFERED MORE COURT
CARE GIVING CLASSES WE MADE IT
PART OF A GENERAL EDUCATION --
COURSE WORK IN COLLEGE AT OUR AT
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES I THINK I
THINK THAT COULD REALLY BE
HELPFUL IT'S IT'S NOT OFFERED
VERY OFTEN NOW --
AND I THINK THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO GO INTO THAT WORK IF IF IT
WAS PRESENTED TO THEM AND IF
THEY WERE AWARE OF IT SO.
I THINK INVESTMENT IN ALL KINDS
OF DIFFERENT LEVELS LIKE THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL AS WE FIGURE
OUT ALL THESE OTHER --
BIG BIG BIG QUESTIONS THAT RELY
UPON ONE ANOTHER.
THINKING.
THANK YOU AN HOUR THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY --
AND I MEAN. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT -- IN
ADDITION --
TO AUTHORING AT SB FIVE TWELVE
TO TRY TO LOOK AT SORT OF THE
HOW WE WOULD FINANCE ESPECIALLY
SUPPORT FOR MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES.
ALSO WORKING WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS SCIENCE SP --
FOUR FORTY TO FOR TASK FORCE ON
SERVING ADULTS WITH US TALKING
TO THE WELFARE DIRECTORS AND
THEY CAME TO ME.
REALIZE THAT --
LOVER SOCIAL SERVICE PROGRAMS
REALLY AREN'T TARGETED TOWARDS
HOLDS -- AND
SO -- AND
THAT -- THEY
RECOGNIZE SUCH THAT THERE'S A
GAP THERE --
CERTAINLY AS A AS A PEDIATRICIAN
WHO TAKES CARE AT THE OTHER END
OF THE AGE SPECTRUM --
I IT IT'S LIKE ME ACCIONES
SPECIAL NEEDS ONE OF THE THINGS
I HEARD FREQUENTLY FROM PARENTS
WAS IS THAT WE HAD.
TO THE AT THE KEY ACCORDING TO
CARE COORDINATORS RIGHT JUST
LOTS NOW SO THE FRAGMENTATION SO
I'D BE SURE YOU BRING THAT UP
I'M.
SURE THAT'S SIMILAR IF THE AT
THE OTHER END OF THE SPECTRUM
AND THAT OFTENTIMES WILL HAPPEN
IS IS THAT WILL HAVE --
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS --
AND NOW THAT COME UP IN
DIFFERENT WAYS AND THEN
MEANWHILE THE FAMILIES ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
NAVIGATE THE MEASURE EVEN AWARE
OF SOME OF THEM.
AND SELL THAT --
LOOKING FOR TO OUR FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS ACTUALLY WITH THE
WITH THE YEAH.
AGENCY ON AGING ABOUT HOW WE
MIGHT BE ABLE.
FULLER SOME OF THAT TOGETHER SO
THERE'S LESS OF A BURDEN ON ON
FAMILIES AS WELL AND ALSO --
MAKE IT EASIER FOR THEM TO BE
AWARE OF AFFAIRSPROGRAMS BUT
CERTAINLY WE WE HAVE BOTH A
CHALLENGE ON BOTH --
NOT ONLY THAT THE TYPE OF
SERVICES WE HAVE AND THEN THE
SCALE WHICH WE ABLE DELIVER THAT
WHICH WE HEARD FROM THE LAST
PANEL.
SO I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR AND I GUESS YOU HAVE
THE BILL ON THE MASTER PLAN ALL
RIGHT LOOKS IKE WE HAVE WHAT.
I LOOK FOR TO TO TO TO SEE HOW
THAT GOES TO AS WELL NAY RECORD
INTENSE UP AS WELL TOGETHER
EXACTLY WHAT WILL ENSURE WE WILL.
SO AND OF COURSE WITH THAT THE
OTHER MEMBERS THIS COMMITTEE AS
WELL SO I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY.
OKAY THANK YOU --
I'LL I WAS I HAD A I HAD A
QUESTION ABOUT --
THE PROCESS IT SEEMS LIKE.
IT'S CUMBERSOME TO GO ASK FOR
CARE.
ORDER THINGS WE HAVE TO DO TO
STREAMLINE.
THE PROCESS FOR PEOPLE TO MAKE
IT SIMPLER --
FOR I I A I'M FAMILIAR WITH --
THE LETTERMAN ACT BECAUSE I HAVE
A FAMILY MEMBER OR THAT.
MY WIFE AND AYE CARE --
FOR FOR A LONG TIME MY STEP SON.
WHO IS IN THE LETTERMAN ACT OKAY
SO SO I FROM EARTH THE
PRESUMPTION THAT IS GIVEN TO
SOMEBODY WITH THE LATTER ENACT?
IT'S THE STATUS I DON'T THINK --
AGING SENIORS HAVE.
THERE DISABLED IS TO SAY WE
SHOULD HAVE.
THE STATUS OF BECAUSE WHAT A
CORPORATE OR CALL PRESUMPTION OF
NEED.
YOU PRESUME THE PERSON NEEDS
THESE THINGS SO YOU DON'T HAVE
TO GO THROUGH.
OF A LOT OF PROCEDURAL KINDS OF
THINGS. TO RECEIVE CARE OR
ASSISTANCE --
AND AND I WONDER I WONDER IF --
WHEN WE LOOK AT?
THE LAWS THE MASTER PLAN AND HOW
WE GO ABOUT THIS.
WE SHOULD HAVE A PRESUMPTION
GIVEN.
SIMILAR TO WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
LATTER ENACT. FOR THOSE THAT
HAVE DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND YOU KNOW I THINK THAT I
THINK -- IT
IT.
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE TO ME.
THAT AND THEN I I HAD A QUESTION
ABOUT INSURANCE --
STATE DISABILITY INSURANCE ANY
THESE KINDS OF SYSTEMS AND BE
EXPANDED.
TO PROVIDE COVERAGE HAVE YOU
HEARD OF ANY OTHER AND YOU HAVE
YOUR ANY OTHER STATES HAVE DONE
ANYTHING IN THESE AREAS.
ANYWHERE ELSE --
YOUR ORGANIZATIONS --
I DON'T KNOW THOSE ARE MY
QUESTIONS DO YOU HAVE.
HAVE YOU FEEL ABOUT WHAT I'M
SAYING.
CURRENTLY THE STI SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE PAID FMILY
LEAVE.
BUT IT ISN'T --
THERE'S NO JOB PROTECTION. FOR
ADDED -- IS
BEING UNDER UTILIZED BY AND I
KNOW SENATOR JACKSON DOES THIS
BY OUR FAMILY CARE GIVERS
BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY'RE JUST NOT --
HEARING ENOUGH ABOUT IT PLUS THE
WAGE REPLACEMENT --
PROBABLY NEEDS TO BE YOU KNOW IF
INCOME --
AND A LITTLE BECAUSE THERE IS
THAT FLEXIBILITY BUT IT'S HARD
TO GET THROUGH THAT SYSTEM I
AMONG THE PANEL FOR WITH EDT AND
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR FAMILY CAREGIVERS WHO.
WHO -- YOU
DON'T HAVE TO TAKE IT ALL AT
ONCE AND YOU CAN TAKE IT
INTERMITTENTLY BUT THE
INTERMITTENT IS VERY DIFFICULT
IN TERMS OF THE PAPERWORK FOR
THAT.
SO GIVE AND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
ABOUT THE SYSTEM I WOULD AGREE
WITH YOU AND THE MORE THAT WE
COULD HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
SYSTEM.
THAT DOES KIND OF SAY COME IN WE
KNOW IF YOU SELF IDENTIFY THAT'S
ONE OF THE HARDER THINGS IS TO
GET THAT CARE GIVERS SELF
IDENTIFICATION.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU JUST UP%
HERE GEARS SPOUSE OR YOUR THE
HUSBAND A YEAR THE DAUGHTER
YOU'RE A GOOD FRIEND TRYING TO
TAKE CARE SOMEONE --
SO WE DO HAVE TO WORK PART OF
THAT IS GETTING THE WORD OUT AND
HAVING ENOUGH.
ADVERTISING AND PEOPLE TO GET
THAT WORD OUT. TO CORRECT THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME AND I'M.
I'M SORRY.
I SEE IT AS A AS A PROCESS THAT
WOULD BE --
PART OF WHEN THE DIAGNOSIS IS
GIVEN.
THAT THEY WOULD BE EITHER.
REFERRED.
TO AN AGENCY OR OF A PLACE THAT.
WE'RE GONNA SEND YOU THERE AND
THEN WHAT THEY DO IS THEY GO
OVER WHATEVER THAT DISEASE
PROCESSES AND WHAT OF THE
SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE IN
CASE YOU SHOULD NEED THEM.
BOB.
I MEAN WHEN I RENT A HEALTH
EDUCATION CENTER I DID THAT AND
I'M NOT A HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONAL I A PROVIDED THE
AGENCY OF THE DIAGNOSIS THEY
WERE GIVEN.
BUT I DIDN'T KNOW ALL THE
SERVICES THAT ARE.
AND THEN I READ IN THE PAPER.
SOME COUNTIES DON'T EVEN OFFER
SOME OF THESE SERVICES SO MY
FAMILY AND MODERATE CAN'T
BENEFIT FROM SOME OF THE
SERVICES WE HAVE HERE.
BECAUSE THEY'RE DIFFERENT SO I
WOULD BE TALKING TO THEM AND
GIVING THEM THE WRONG
INFORMATION SO WHEN MY FATHER
Là WAS DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER I
WENT TO THE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY TO FIND OUT WHAT.
WHAT?
WE COULD DO ARE I COULD DO TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE PROCESS OF
OF CANCER AND WHAT WE COULD DO --
IT WASN'T FROM THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM IT WAS ON MY OWN BUT YET
I'M.
I KNEW BECAUSE I WAS RUNNING THE
CENTER.
WHEN MY MOTHER LONG GOT
DIAGNOSED WITH ALZHEIMER'S I
WENT TO THE ALSO --
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION TO SEE.
YOU KNOW WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
SERVICES THAT ARE THERE AND THE
WORLD LOT LACKING THEIR THEIR
NON PROFITS THEY RUN ON PEOPLE'S
DONATIONS.
THEY'RE NOT FUNDED BY --
YOU NO WELL THIS IS WHAT WE CAN
PROVIDE FOR YOU.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO ASK FOR
BECAUSE YOUR CALL TO TO HELP
FAMILY MEMBER AND YOU DO IT.
I MEAN THAT'S THE WAY WE'RE-RAISES ALL I THINK WHEN YOU'RE
GIVEN THE DIAGNOSIS THERE SHOULD
BE [inaudible]
OF OF SOMEONE WITHIN YOUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM I MEAN INSURANCE
PREMIUMS ARE NOT ARE JUST NOT
SHOULDN'T JUST BE.
TO HEAL YOUR BODY AT THAT POINT
BUT TO TO HELP.
TRANSITION YOU TO THE NEXT PHASE
TO GET YOU GOING IT DOESN'T MEAN
THEY HAVE TO COVER EVERYTHING
BUT THERE SHOULD BE A PATHWAY
AND THERE'S NOT.
I MEAN I DON'T KNOW WHERE TO GO
EXCEPT FOR MY EXPERIENCE IN.
DOING THAT THAT I WOULD PROBABLY
CALL AN ORGANIZATION THAT.
DEPENDS ON WHO I GET
[inaudible]
SO JUST.
JUST TO BUILD ON THAT I I THINK.
PARTICULAR WITH ALZHEIMER'S AND
OTHER DEMENTIAS IT'S AS IF HIS
BRAIN DISEASE --
LEADING KILLER IN THE STATE.
AND YET WE GET A DIAGNOSIS FOR
MEDICAL PROVIDER.
SOMETIMES RELUCTANTLY OR WITH
MUCH DIFFICULTY.
AND THEN IT SEEMS LIKE A HEALTH
PLAN SHOULD BE MORE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
SERVICES AS WELL.
OBVIOUSLY WE HIT PRESCRIPTIONS
WITH -- AND
REFERRAL STERN NUMEROLOGIST AND
SOME OTHER CARE ABOUT DURABLE
EQUIPMENT.
BUT DID YOU SEE MORE THIS THE
FIRST FAMILY.
IN THE IN A MAY BE SIMILAR TO
HEALTH THINGS --
DEALT WITH WITH AUTISM.
ON A FEW YEARS CRISIS OF IS NOW
UNDER THE LETTERMAN YEAH.
THAT YOU KNOW MORE IS THE
CONTROL DECK THIS ISN'T GOING TO
TAKE CARE OF IT IS JUST THE
BEGINNING OF A LONG AND ARDUOUS
JOURNEY.
AND WHAT IS THE ROLE OF THE
HEALTH PLAN IN HELPING --
THE INDIVIDUAL AND THE FAMILY
WITH THIS FATAL AT THIS POINT
CHRONIC DISEASE.
HOPEFULLY THINGS WILL CHANGE IN
THE FUTURE BUT THAT'S NOT A
REALITY TODAY.
YEAH I LIKE TO THINK WERE YOUR
MOM FOR SERVICE TO MY COMMUNITY.
SALAS AND ALSO LIKE TO THANK
YOUR SON. FOR HIS WORK AS MY A
LEGISLATIVE ASSISTANT.
TAKE IT.
OUT OF HIM.
BUT I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR MOM WAS A WONDERFUL PERSON
SHE WAS WELL RESPECTED AND WELL
KNOWN IS A POWERFUL WOMAN IN.
SAN JOSE AND WITH SAYS ARE JUST
SAYS -- ALSO
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK [inaudible]
GOODNESS.
SO OUR THIRD AND FINAL PANEL
WILL DISCUSS RESOURCES AND
SUPPORTS THE PROMISING
DIRECTIONS.
BY ONCE AGAIN WILL SET A TIME
LIMIT FOR PALACE AT FIVE TO
SEVEN MINUTES AND THEN OPEN FOR
QUESTIONS FROM OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
MISTER COREY PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU ARE READY [inaudible]
RICHARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOE
CLOVER I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
PASSAGES.
AND PASSAGE IS IS A GREAT
SERVICE PROGRAM TO CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY CHICO RESEARCH
FOUNDATION --
I'M FORTUNATE IN THAT --
MY AGENCIES A DESIGNATED.
AREA AGENCY ON AGING AND WE ARE
A DESIGNATED CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTER.
OFF SO I HAVE BOTH FEDERAL FUNDS
IN STATE FUNDS AND ON THAT IT
GIVES ME SOME GREAT ADVANTAGES --
I'M ABLE TO PROVIDE.
A FULL MENU OF SERVICES FOR CARE
GIVERS THAT IF I WAS JUST CARE
GIVE RESOURCE CENTER REGISTRABLE
A WOULD BE LIMITED SO.
I FEEL FORTUNATE --
HAVING BOTH FUNDING STREAMS NOT
ONLY GIVES ME A BETTER A MENU OF
SERVICES TO OFFER.
BUT IT ALSO ALLOWS ME TO MATCH
THOSE DOLLARS AGAINST EACH OTHER
AND I THINK AT LONG MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT --
UNDER THE TRIPLE A.'S THAT IT IS
LOCAL COMMUNITIES RESPONSIBLE
FOR COMING UP WITH THE MATCH AND
SO THE STATE FUNDED CARE
RESOURCE CENTER ALLOWS ME TO
PROVIDE THE TWENTY FIRST PERCENT
25% MATCH THE PROGRAM.
BUT AGAIN I THINK MOST
IMPORTANTLY I'M ABLE. TO TO
LEVERAGE MORE SERVICES FOR THE
CARE GIVERS NOW THAT MY SERVICE
AREA IT.
CONSTITUTES TEN COUNTIES IS
QUITE LARGE --
IT'S VERY CHALLENGING --
IF YOU'RE A CARE GIVER AND
YOU'RE LIVING IN --
AND YOU NEED ASSISTANCE --
IT'S A LONG WAY TO TRAVEL IF
YOU'RE GONNA GO SEE A SPECIALIST
YOU KNOW YOU'RE TRAVELING TO
DAVIS OR YOUR TRAVELING
SACRAMENTO --
INFORMALLY WE'VE KIND OF FIGURED
IT COULD BE LIKE FIVE SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR SOMEBODY
TAKE A TRIP TO THE HOSPITAL.
BUT THE PERSON THAT'S IN A
SEPARATE ALZHEIMER'S AND SUCH SO.
THERE'S SOME REAL CHALLENGES IN
OUR AREA --
PART OF THOSE CHALLENGES HAS
REQUIRED THAT WE APPROACH OUR
SERVICES A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT --
WE HAVE TO BE VERY FLEXIBLE WITH
THEIR CARE GIVERS --
SO THEY CAN ACCESS OUR PROGRAMS.
SO --
RESPITE IS TALKED A LOT ABOUT
AND IT'S IT'S A WONDERFUL
PROGRAM FOR CAREGIVERS THEY
NEEDED BUT THE FUNDING THAT WE
HAVE WE JUST WE DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GIVE RESPITE TO EVERY
CARE GIVER.
NOT ONLY THAT SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE STILL RURAL
THERE'S NOT EVEN REALLY THE
SOCIAL SERVICES INFRASTRUCTURE
TO PROVIDE THESE SERVICES AGAIN
ALL THESE MODOC COUNTY OR
TRINITY COUNTY.
TRYING TO FIND AN ORGANIZATION
THAT HAS --
RESPITE WORKERS PLUMAS COUNTY
YOU KNOW WE'VE WE'VE WORKED ON
CONTRACTS AND GUESS WHAT.
YOU'VE GOT FOUR HOURS A MONTH
FOR ME.
NO ONE'S GOING TO DO THAT SO IS
THERE SOME REAL CHALLENGES WITH
IT SO WELL RESPITE.
IS AREA.
CRITICAL IMPORTANT PIECE THE
SERVICE WE REALLY EMBRACE THE
EMPOWERMENT MODEL OF THE CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS AND THE
AND THE TITLE THREE CARE GIVER
PROGRAMS.
THAT WERE REALLY WORKING WITH
OUR CLIENTS RULES THE EDUCATION
THE TRAINING TO CARE FOR THE
FOLKS AT HOME AND WALL RESPITE
IS ALWAYS THERE AND IT'S PART OF
THAT IT'S IT'S NOT THE COMPLETE
PACKAGE.
AND I WANT TO SHARE A STORY
ABOUT ONE OF OUR CARE GIVERS
THAT'D COME TO US AND IT WAS A
COUPLE YEARS BACK.
THIS PERSON CAME AND WAS A
LITTLE DESPONDENT WAS INTERESTED
IN THE PROGRAM BUT WASN'T QUITE
SURE.
BUT WE INVITED HER TO OUR ANNUAL
RETREAT IT'S A THREE DAY RETREAT
WHERE WE TAKE THE CARE GIVERS
WOULD TAKE AWAY WE COULDN'T
EDUCATION TRAINING --
WE PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEM TO BE OUT OF THE HOUSE --
DO SOME SELF FULFILLMENT SOME
SELF GROWTH.
AND CHEERFUL STAND OFFICE SHE
LIKE THE PROGRAM BUT THEN SHE
WASN'T QUITE THERE.
BUT SHE CAME BACK IN TO CONTINUE
WITH OUR PROGRAM SHE DID --
WEEKLY MONTHLY --
SUPPORT GROUPS --
SHE TENDED.
AND SHE BUT STILL STANDOFFISH
AND THEN THE SECOND YEAR SHE
CAME BACK AND DID THREE TREAT
WITH US AGAIN AND THIS YEAR.
WE SAW A DEFINITE DIFFERENCE AND
HER -- SHE
ASKED A ROOM WITH ONE OF THE
OTHER CARE GIVERS SHE WAS MORE
ENGAGED THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE
WEEKEND IN THE PROCESS.
AND NOT TOO LONG AGO WE GOT A
CALL FROM RECENT MAKE SURE YOU
PUT ME DOWN ONCE AGAIN I WANT TO
GO TO THE RETREAT THIS YEAR
WHICH WAS A REALLY GOOD SIGN.
IT WAS INTERESTING WHEN WE LOOK
BACK AT HER --
RECORD THAT EACH YEAR SINCE THE
BEGINNING SHE ASKED FOR LESS AND
LESS RESPITE BECAUSE HE HAD
GAINED THE TOOLS FROM THESE
PROGRAMS TO CARE FOR HER FAMILY
MEMBER BUT I THINK AS
IMPORTANTLY TO CARE FOR HERSELF
SO SHE WASN'T AS DEPENDENT ON
THIS PROGRAM.
NOW.
IN MY TENT COUNTIES WE HAVE A
BUDGET OF ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS SO
IN SOME WAYS IS PRETTY GOOD WERE
SERVING ABOUT. TWO HUNDRED
REGISTERED FAMILY CAREGIVERS IN
OUR PROGRAM.
IF I IF I RUN THAT OUT IN THE
YEAR IT'S ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER CARE
GIVER.
NOW YOU COMPARE THAT TO WHAT THE
COST OF THE BED Là SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY AS AND I WOULD
ARGUE THE MAJORITY OF THOSE TWO
HUNDRED PEOPLE COULD PROBABLY BE
IN A BAD.
BUT IT'S THAT CARE GIVER THOSE
WILLING.
TO STICK WITH THE PARENT STICK
WITH HER AUNT OR UNCLE THEIR
LOVED ONE AND WORK WITH THEM.
BUT I THINK THE ONLY WAY THAT
THEY CAN REALLY DO THAT
SUCCESSFULLY.
IS IF THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
CARE GIVER PROGRAMS SO THAT'S
KINDOF OUR STORY AND AND I'VE
GOT.
PLENTY MORE DETAILS BUT I THINK
OTHER PEOPLE NEED TO SPEAK GONNA
SAY THAT.
THESE ARE INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMS AND I THINK SOME
QUESTIONS THAT CAME UP IN THE
LAST PANEL WHAT ARE SOME THINGS
WE CAN LOOK AT AND DO TO BRING
FORWARD.
I THINK BETWEEN THE CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE TRIPLE A.'S YOU HAVE A
PHENOMENAL INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
ALREADY EXISTS IT'S IN PLACE AND
IT'S BEEN IN PLACE FOR A LONG
TIME.
I THINK WITH RELATIVELY.
MINOR AMOUNT OF FUNDING.
THIS EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE CAN
BE ALTERING FOR THE DIRECTION I
THINK THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS GOING NOW
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
IT'S YOU --
FOR YOU WILL GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS SERRA STAINED HAUSEN.
AND I'M SENIOR POLICY ADVISER
WITH TH SCANNED FOUNDATION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
FOR THE INVITATION TO TESTIFY.
YOU'VE HEARD A LOT.
ABOUT TREMENDOUS INSIGHT INTO
THE RANGE OF ISSUES THAT IMPACT
OUR CARE GIVERS AS WELL AS THE
REALLY IMPORTANT RESOURCES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO SERVE THE
POPULATION.
BUT THE FOCUS OF MY REMARKS
ACTUALLY STEMS FROM A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATION YOU JUST HAD IN THE
PRIOR PANEL WHICH IS REALLY
CRITICAL.
IT RELATES TO HOW CARE GIVERS
ACCESS THE INFORMATION AND
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED.
ARMS SO L. L. ELOQUENTLY
EXPRESSED BY MRS SALDOVAR MISS
MARK HAS AND DR BENTON WHEN CARE
GIVERS ARE PLACED INTO A
SITUATION WHERE THEY KNOW THAT
THEIR LOVED.
ONE NEED SOME SORT OF SUPPORT IN
THE HOME OR IN THE COMMUNITY.
THEY USUALLY DON'T KNOW WHERE TO
GO FOR HELP THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY NEED AND THEY DON'T KNOW
HOW TO GET IT.
SO EVERY DAY WE HEAR STORIES OF
PEOPLE STRUGGLING TO WEAVE
TOGETHER THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS THAT THEY NEED TO
REMAIN AT HOME AND AVOID
INSTITUTIONALIZATION.
FAMILIES DON'T KNOW WHERE TO
TURN FOR HELP SERVICES THEIR
BOUNCE BETWEEN PROGRAMS WITH
LITTLE ASSURANCES THAT THEIR
NEEDS CAN BE MET.
SO THE THE PROBLEM IS REALLY
MULTI FACETED AND THERE'S A
NUMBER OF REASONS WHY THE SYSTEM
IS LIKE THIS AND SO FRAGMENTED.
ON MOST OF THESE PROGRAMS THAT
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA
DIFFERENT FUNDING STREAMS ARE
RUN OUT OF SOMETIMES DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS.
AND THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
ASSESSMENT PROCESS SEES THOSE
YOU'VE HEARD YOU CAN BE BOUNCED
AROUND FROM PROGRAM TO PROGRAM
WITH DIFFERENT ASSESSMENTS.
AND NOT KNOWING WHETHER YOU'RE
GOING TO GET EVERYTHING YOU NEED.
BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT IT
IS AS A STATE WE CAN DO A LOT
BETTER.
THEY'RE IS PROMISING POTENTIAL
TO MEET INDIVIDUAL NEEDS AND A
MORE HUMAN CENTERED FASHION WITH
ACCESS TO A SEAMLESS SET OF
SERVICES.
SO AS AN EXAMPLE CALIFORNIA'S
AGING AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CENTERS WHICH ARE CALLED EIGHTY
ARE SEIZE.
AND BASIC TO DO JUST THIS THEY
TRY TO STREAMLINE ACCESS TO
INFORMATION AND SUPPORTS FOR
OLDER ADULTS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
FAMILY CARE GIVERS AND VETERANS
ANYBODY WHO NEEDS SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS. EIGHTY ARE SEIZE
OPERATE AS A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING AND
CENTERS FOR INDEPENDENT LIVING.
AND THEY PROVIDE INFORMATION AND
REFERRAL COUNSELING ABOUT
AVAILABLE L. TSS LONG TERM
SERVICE PRO SUPPORTS PROGRAMS
AND BENEFITS.
SHORT TERM SERVICE COORDINATION
SO IF YOU NEED A LITTLE HELP IN
CONNECTING YOUR LOVED ONE WITH A
SERVICE OR SUPPORT THEY CAN
PROVIDE THAT.
AS WELL IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TRANSITION HOT --
SERVICES WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL
TRANSIT WHEN THEY TRANSITION
FROM A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
BACK HOME THOSE ARE OFTEN THE
MOST CRITICAL TIMES WHEN PEOPLE
NEED SERVICES AND SUPPORTS ITS
IN THOSE MOMENTS OF TRANSITION.
BUT ULTIMATELY THIS MODEL SEEKS
TO EMPOWER THE CONSUMER TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO MAKE THE MOST INFORMED
CHOICES FOR THEMSELVES.
AT WAR ON WITH THEIR LOVED ONES.
THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT IN
CALIFORNIA EIGHTY ARE SEIZE ARE
AVAILABLE IN ONLY EIGHT OF OUR
COUNTIES. TO DATE THERE HAS BEEN
NO STATE GENERAL FUND RESOURCES
COMMITTED TO THE EFFORT.
AND IN THEIR ONLY HAS BEEN VERY
LIMITED FUNDING COMING FROM
FEDERAL GRANTS SO COUNTIES ARE
LEFT RIGHT NOW THOSE THAT DO
OPERATE THESE PROGRAMS THEY'RE
TRYING TO PULL TOGETHER THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED.
JUST TO KEEP THEM GOING.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
BUILD ITS EIGHTY ARE SYNCED AB
R. C. SYSTEM INTO SOMETHING
THAT'S MUCH MORE IN LINE WITH
ITS VISION INTO A NO WRONG DOOR
SYSTEM.
WITH STREAMLINED ACCESS TO
INFORMATION AND SUPPORTS IN ALL
AREAS OF THE STATE WHERE ANYONE
CAN BE CONNECTED TO THE FULL
RANGE OF COMMUNITY BASED OF
OPTIONS AVAILABLE.
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY ENTER
THE SYSTEM.
ULTIMATELY THIS APPROACH HELPS
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR CARE
GIVERS NAVIGATE RESOURCES THEY
NEED FOR A MORE PERSON CENTERED
APPROACH. TO WHAT WE REALLY NEED
RIGHT NOW IS FROM THE STATE IS
LEADERSHIP AND THE INVESTMENT
INTO MAKING THIS VISION A
REALITY.
WE HAVE SEEN OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE DONE THIS QUITE
SUCCESSFULLY WASHINGTON HAS A NO
WRONG DOOR SYSTEM --
AND THEY HAD A REALLY CLEAR FIVE
YEAR PLAN OF WHAT IT WOULD TAKE
TO BUILD OUT THERE AT RC SYSTEM
TO BE A STATE WIDE NO WRONG DOOR
SYSTEM.
THEY HAVE LEVERAGE TECHNOLOGY
AND DEVELOPED A SINGLE UNIFIED
ASSESSMENT PROCESS TO ENABLE
COORDINATED ACCESS TO SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SUCCESSFUL MODELS ARE OR NEW
EMERGING MODELS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT HELP OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID HOW I'M SEEKING ACCESS
TO INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED TO
MAKE MORE INFORMED DECISIONS ON
SPECIFICALLY ON THEIR HEALTH
CARE SERVICE DELIVERY OPTIONS.
WE SEE NEW PLATFORMS EMERGING
SUCH AS THAT OFFERED BY A
WEBSITE CALLED MY ARE MY CHOICE
THAT HELPS INDIVIDUALS
UNDERSTAND THEIR RANGE OF NEEDS.
THE EIGHTY R. C. MODEL HOLDS
TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL TO BE TO BE
BUILT INTO A NO WRONG DOOR
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA BUT THIS
POTENTIAL CAN ONLY BE REALIZED
WITH THE LEADERSHIP AND
COMMITMENT FROM THE STATE.
SO I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT --
TO AND TO HAVING THIS HEARING
AND FOR SHINING A LIGHT ON THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S FAMILY
CARE GIVERS I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING ON RECOGNIZING THE
BENEFITS THE NEEDS OF FAMILY
CARE GIVERS I AM VERY HAPPY TO
BE THE FINAL PRESENTER ON THIS
PANEL.
MY NAME IS STEPHANIE WILSON AND
I AM THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
THE TRIPLE OUR ADULT DAY PROGRAM
HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
AND I ALSO SERVE ON THE CATS
BOARD OF DIRECTORS AS THEIR VICE
PRESIDENT.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
ADULT DAY SERVICES ALSO KNOWN AS
CADS.
IS A NOT FOR PROFIT ORGAN AT NOT
FOR PROFIT ASSOCIATION THAT HAS
BEEN SUPPORTING ADVANCING AND
LEADING ADULT DAY SERVICES SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN AND IT
WAS VERY GRATIFYING TO HEAR SO
MANY INSTANCES THIS --
DURING THIS PANEL OF PEOPLE
USING ADULT DAY.
CATS REPRESENTS ALL LICENSE
FORMS OF ADULT DAY SERVICES
INCLUDING ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE
KNOWN AS EIGHTY EIGHT TO SEE.
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES.
ALSO NOTE KNOWN AS SEA BASS AN
ADULT A SUPPORT PROGRAMS AND
REGIONAL CENTER VENDOR IS
PROGRAMS.
IN CALIFORNIA THERE ARE TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT EIGHTY
EIGHT CC BASS CENTERS WHICH ARE
LICENSED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH PUBLIC
HEALTH AND OUR CERTIFIED FOR
MEDI CAL BY.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
AGING THERE ARE ALSO TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY EIGHT ADULT DAY
SUPPORT PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
STATE WHICH ARE LICENSED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
CATS PHILOSOPHY INCLUDES A
PERSON CENTERED CARE THAT
EMPHASIZES CHOICE IN
INDEPENDENCE THROUGH AN
ALTERNATIVE O INSTITUTIONAL
CARE.
THAT WORKS IN COLLABORATION WITH
MEDICAL PROVIDERS FORMAL AND
INFORMAL CAREGIVERS AND
COMMUNITY SERVICES.
I WOULD LIKE TO JUST TALK JUST
FOR A FEW MY PARTICULAR PROGRAM
WHICH IS A LICENSED ADULT DAY
SOCIAL MODEL --
FOCUSED ON DEMENTIA CARE
OPERATED BY THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO TO GIVE YOU JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND ABOUT
HOW ADULT DAY PROGRAM SUPPORT
FAMILY CAREGIVERS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO OPENED
OUR FIRST TRIPLE OUR ADULT DAY
CENTER TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AGO A
FEW BLOCKS AWAY FROM THE CAPITAL
AT THE HEART SENIOR CENTER. TO
ALLOW CARE GIVERS RESPITE FROM
THERE ROUND THE CLOCK DUTIES AND
TO PROVIDE A PLACE OF BELONGING
FOR PEOPLE WITH DEMENTIA.
COULD BE ACTIVE AND SOCIALIZE
WHILE ALSO GETTING THEIR
PERSONAL CARE NEEDS ADDRESSED.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY TWO THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO HAS OPENED
TWO ADDITIONAL SITES FOR A TOTAL
OF THREE SITES.
THAT TOGETHER CURRENTLY SERVE
APPROXIMATELY HUNDRED FAMILIES
PER DAY.
GENERALLY THE OLDER ADULTS WITH
DEMENTIA IS LIVING IN THE HOME
WITH THE FAMILY MEMBER.
OFTEN WHEN OF OF THEIR ADULT
CHILDREN THE PRIMARY CARE GIVER
USUALLY HAS HIS.
FAMILY OF HIS OR HER ON THAT
THEY'RE RAISING AND ARE ALSO
WORKING EITHER PART OR FULL TIME.
SO THEY FALL INTO THE CATEGORY
THAT WE ARE NOW RECOGNIZING AS
THE QUOTE ON QUOTE SANDWICH
GENERATION.
TAKING CARE OF BOTH THEIR
CHILDREN AND THEIR PARENTS AT
THE SAME TIME.
CARE GIVERS MUST BALANCE THE
CARE NEEDS OF THE OLDER ADULT
WITH THEIR OWN NEED TO WORK AND
BUILD RETIREMENT SAVINGS FOR
THEMSELVES.
AT TRIPLE ARE WE ARE OPEN LONG
PROGRAM SIX PM TO ALLOW A CARE
GIVER TO DROP THEIR PARENT OFF
BEFORE WORK AND PICK THEM UP
AFTER WORK.
IN ADDITION WE OFFER SATURDAY
PROGRAM HOURS QUARTERLY TO GIVE
CARE GIVERS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
TRUE RESPITE. TO GO TO THE
MOVIES OR THEIR CHILD'S SOCCER
GAME OR JUST GO HOME AND TAKE A
NAP.
WHEN A FAMILY CHOOSES TRIPLE OUR
OUR STAFF IN THE PERSON?
OF THE FAMILY THAT THE FAMILY OF
THE PERSON WITH DEMENTIA BECOMES
A CARE TEAM --
AS CERTIFIED DEMENTIA CAPABLE
SPECIALISTS WE TRAIN OUR STAFF
IN PERSON CENTERED CARE.
CREATE A PERSONALIZED CARE PLAN
FOR EACH MEMBER OF OUR PROGRAM
WE USE OUR KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERIENCE TO DETERMINE WHAT
DEMENTIA COMMUNICATION
STRATEGIES WORK BEST FOR EACH
INDIVIDUAL.
AND WE THEN SHARE THOSE
STRATEGIES WITH THE FAMILY TO
USE AT HOME.
IN ANNUAL SURVEYS CONDUCTED WAS
PARTICIPATING FAMILIES ARE OVER
70% REPORT THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR LOVED
ONE LONGER AT HOME.
AVOIDING INSTITUTIONALIZATION
THAN THEY WOULD HAVE WITHOUT THE
SUPPORT OF ADULT DAY.
POTENTIALLY SAVING A LOT OF
MONEY.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN OTHER WAY
SPENT ON LONG.
TERM CARE OUTSIDE THE HOME.
THEY ALSO REPORTED TO THE OLDER
ADULT BETTER AT NIGHT AND
DISPLAYS LESS ANXIETY AFTER A
DAY ON THE PROGRAM. TO ENCOURAGE
THE CARE GIVERS EMOTIONAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH --
TRIPLER PROVIDES SEVERAL SUPPORT
PROGRAM SO THIS IS OUTSIDE OF
THE ADULT DAY PROGRAM ITSELF WE
HAVE A MONTHLY SUPPORT GROUP
MEETING THAT WE CO FACILITY WITH
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION.
AND IN ADDITION WE HAVE TO MOLD
SAY SIR SERIES INTENSIVE STATE
MEET BIMONTHLY FOR FIVE MONTHS
ONE OF THESE INTENSIVES FOCUSES
ON CURRENT CARE GIVERS AND HOW
TO MAINTAIN THEIR OWN.
PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL AND SPIRITUAL
HEALTH TO OPTIMALLY CARE FOR
THEMSELVES TO AVOID CAREGIVER
BURNOUT SERVER PROVIDING
TRAINING NOT ONLY AND HOW TO
CARE.
FOR THE OLDER ADULT BUT ALSO HOW
TO KEEP THEMSELVES HEALTHY AND
AVOIDING BURN OUT WE ALSO HAVE A
SECOND INTENSIVE --
THERE WAS SOME TALK ABOUT THIS
EARLIER IN THE PANEL --
FOCUSING ON PEOPLE WHO ARE NO
LONGER CARE GIVERS DUE TO THE-DEATH OF THEIR LOVED ONE AND
THEY'RE HAVING A REALLY HARD
TIME GETTING BACK ON TRACK AND
MOVING THROUGH THEIR GRIEF TO A
NEW LIFE.
SO THESE ARE PEOPLE OF SOMEBODY
MENTIONED THAT THEY HAD PROVIDED
CARE FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS.
THAT'S A REALLY LONG TIME THAT
YOU'VE BEEN DOING THE SAME THING
YEAR AFTER YEAR AND THEN
SUDDENLY WHEN THAT JOB GOES AWAY
PEOPLE HAVE.
A CRISIS.
WE ALSO OFFER QUARTERLY
WORKSHOPS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
DORO CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER
ON SOME OF THE LOGISTICAL
ASPECTS OF CARE GIVIG.
TOPICS IN THESE WORKSHOPS
INCLUDE HOW GIVING INFORMATION
AND RESOURCES FOR LEGAL
FINANCIAL AND MEDICAL QUESTIONS
HOW TO PREVENT FALLS AT HOME AND
MUCH MORE.
OUR MONTHLY SUPPORT GROUP AND
QUARTERLY WORKSHOPS ARE FREE.
THE FIVE MONTH INTENSIVE ARE
TWENTY DOLLARS FOR THE ENTIRE
SERIES.
DALY FEES IN THE TRIPLE OUR
PROGRAM ARE ROUGHLY EQUIVALENT
TO FOUR HOURS OF IN HOME CARE
FOR PROGRAM DAY THAT'S OPEN
ABOUT TEN AND A HALF AT THE IS
OPEN TEN AND A HALF HOURS.
AT TRIPLE OR HAS A COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDE AT LEAST ONE DAY A WEEK
OF SERVICE TO ANY CAREGIVER WHO
EXPRESSES THE NEED FOR RESPITE.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ABILITY TO
PAY.
WE PREFER PROCURE ANNUAL GRANTS
FOR SCHOLARSHIP TO HONOR THIS
COMMITMENT AND WE ARE ALSO
GRATEFUL FOR AS A STRONG
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR LOCAL CARE
GIVER RESOURCE CENTER.
WE BELIEVE THAT EVERY UNIT OF
SERVICE OF ADULT DAY CARE.
SERVICE WE PROVIDE WE ARE
DIRECTLY AFFECTING THE WELL
BEING OF BOTH THE CARE GIVER AND
THE OLDER ADULTS WHO ATTENDS OUR
PROGRAM.
FINELY BECAUSE IT IS A VISION OF
TRIPLE ARE THAT ALL PEOPLE WITH
DEMENTIA AT FEEL ACCEPTED IN OUR
COMMUNITY THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO
LAUNCH DEMENTIA FRIENDLY
SACRAMENTO AST YEAR. TO PROVIDE
DEMENTIA COMMUNICATION TRAINING
THE FRONTLINE STAFF AT RETAIL
ESTABLISHMENTS RESTAURANTS AND
GROCERY STORES TO REDUCE STIGMA
AROUND DEMENTIA AND MAKE IT
EASIER FOR A CARE GIVER TO
INCLUDE THE OLDER ADULT.
AND FUN EVENTS AND ACTIVITIES
WE'VE ALSO CREATED AN ELDER CARE
RESOURCES WORKSHOP THAT IS
PROVIDED THROUGH THE CITY
SACRAMENTO CITY OF SACRAMENTO HR
DEPARTMENT TO EMPLOYEES.
AND COULD BE RECKLESS WERE
REPLICATED EXCUSE ME. TO OTHER
COMPANIES AND ORGANIZATIONS MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE ARE PROUD TO
SERVE FAMILY CARE GIVERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO THE ENTIRE CARE
GIVING EXPERIENCE.
BEFORE EITHER THEIR CARE GIVERS
IF THEY CAN GO TO AN HR.
MEETING ALL THE WAY TO THE AND
WERE PROVIDING FRONTIER NEW LIFE.
INNOVATIVE ADULT DAY PROGRAM
SUCH AS TRIPLE OUR EXIST
THROUGHOUT THE STATE EVERY
PROGRAM IS DIFFERENT AND THAT'S
THE BEAUTY OF THE MODEL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AND I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH --
FOR THE WORK YOU DO TO ASSIST
OUR FAMILY CARE GIVERS AND THE
LOVE ONCE THROUGHOUT THE STATE I
JUST HAD --
COUPLE QUESTIONS --
THE FIRST ONE BEING CATHOLIC
WAITING LIST --
BUT TO GET HIM A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT KIND OF LIKE.
THE NEED IN.
WE HAVE SEVERAL DIFFERENT --
THE THREE DIFFERENT SITES ARE --
ON PURPOSE WE PROVIDE DIFFERENT --
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DIFFERENT
CLIENTELE WHEN A VERY SITE IS --
ON AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL CAMPUS
AND IT IS FOR EARLY STAGE MEMORY
LOSS.
AND THAT PROGRAM IS DOES HAVE A
WAITING LIST RIGHT NOW --
THE OTHER TWO SITES --
CAN PROVIDE CARE FOR PEOPLE FROM
EARLY STAGE --
ALL THE WAY TO END STAGE THEM
AND SOMETIMES IS FULL BUT OFTEN
WERE ABLE TO GET PEOPLE AND
FAIRLY QUICKLY WE REALLY TRY --
TO ACCOMMODATE PEOPLE AT LEAST
ONE DAY A WEEK TO START EVEN IF --
FOR YEAH HAVE A WAITING LIST OF
SOME SORT IS A REASON WHY IT
KIND OF VARIES FROM ONE WHO.
YOU KNOW AT THE WAITING LIST
FROM ONE AREA TO ANOTHER OR ONE
CENTER --
THEIR EARLY STAGE MEMORY LOSS
SITE IS PROBABLY THE MOST IN
DEMAND RIGHT NOW WHICH IS LIKELY
WHY -- WE
HAVE SUCH IN THAT IS WHERE
WAITING LIST IS RIGHT NOW AND
IT'S ALSO --
WE CAN ACCOMMODATE OF LAGE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE AT THE OTHER
TWO SITES AND WE REALLY NEED TO
LIMIT THE NUMBER.
TO TWENTY AT THE EARLY STAGE
MEMORY LOSS SITE AND SO --
THAT'S MOSTLY ITS CAPACITY TO BE
HONEST YEAH.
CHALCOGEN OPENED UP HER
COMMITTEE MEMBER SEE THINGS HAVE
QUESTIONS.
OPTICAL.
CENTER PASS UP THANK YOU.
I'D YOU'VE YOU MAY HAVE ANY
IDEAS I ASKED THIS OF THE I'LL.
FIVE AGING.
DETAIL OF HIS ANSWERS WAS WELL
MAYBE THE LOCAL AREA AGING EMC
FAIRLY --
HANDS ON MORE WORK AND ACTION
GOT ONE IN FOUR OF FAMILIES
WOULD WOULD HAVE A CHARACTER SO
BASED ON I'LL GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF
ONE OF OUR COUNTIES.
ABOUT -- TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND WE'RE HITTING A
HUNDRED TO TWO HUNDRED I'VE I
CALCULATED IT POINT ZERO ZERO
TWO BEFORE ACTUALLY SERVING.
NOW.
I THINK THE OTHER POINT THAT WAS
BROUGHT OUT IS.
IDENTIFIED AS A CARE GIVER IS.
IS IS IS KIND OF A NATURAL
BARRIER --
YOU SEE SOMEBODY CARING FOR
SOMEBODY SAY HEY WE HAVE
SERVICES YOU MIGHT WANT TO COME.
AND CONSIDER GET HER CARE GIVER
SERVICES AND OFTENTIMES WILL GET
THE RESPONSE FROM ON WOULD BE OF
NO I DON'T NEED ANY SERVICES
IT'S MY IT'S MY MOTHER IS MY
HOUSE AND THEY NEED TO SERVICES
SO SELF IDENTIFICATION IS.
IS A HUGE BARRIER TO THIS
PROCESS --
SO IT'S SOMETHING I THINK I
WOULD I WOULD REALLY CONSIDER
AND IN MY EXPERIENCE --
AS THE TRIPLE A DIRECTOR OFTEN
MY INTRODUCTION TO CARE GIVERS
AS WHEN I HAVE SOMEBODY WALK
INTO OUR OFFICE FRANTIC I'M
TAKING CARE OF MY MOTHER I DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO.
MODEL MEDI CAL PAY FOR IN HOME
CARE SO A COMPLETE LACK OF
KNOWLEDGE OF POWER SYSTEMS WORK
AND THE FIRST TIME THE EVEN
DISCOVER THAT THEY'RE A CARE
GIVER.
IS ONE IT'S AT THIS CRISIS
MOMENT SO.
THE CHALLENGE OF IDENTIFIED AS A
CARE GIVER IS THE FIRST
IDENTIFIED THAT I'M I MEAN THE
SITUATION THAT REALLY OST
FAMILIES HAVE NEVER PREPARE FOR
SEE ALMOST HAVE TO GET OVER THAT
INITIAL SHOCK BUT AGAIN I WOULD
SAY WE WERE HITTING A VERY SMALL
FRACTION.
OF THE CARE GIVERS THAT ARE OUT
THERE.
SO YES THE FOLLOW UP IS IS THAT
YOU MENTIONED SMALL FRACTION WE
ALSO MENTION THAT PEOPLE DON'T
TEND AND THAT A FIGHT SO YES.
DO YOU FIND YOURSELF OBVIOUSLY
WE NEED WORK TO HELP PEOPLE
IDENTIFIED DO YOU FIND YOURSELF
WITH.
LONG WAITING LISTS ANYWAY THE
WAITING WAS QUESTION FOR YEAH
ADD VERSES OR IS IT THAT
ACTUALLY ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY.
SELF IDENTIFY.
YOU'RE ABLE TO HELP --
ARE YES IT MOST PEOPLE THAT CALL
US THAT IDENTIFIES WE CAN HELP
BUT WE OFFER A HUGE MENU OF
SERVICES SO RIGHT SOMEONE SAYING
I NEED RESPITE THAT MIGHT BE A
LIMITED SERVICE.
BECAUSE THERE IS LIMITED FUNDS
BUT WE CAN ALWAYS PROVIDE FAMILY
CONSULTANT TO THEM --
WE DO NUMEROUS EDUCATION AND
TRAINING CLASSES THROUGHOUT THE
REGION SO YOU COULD BE A FAMILY
CARE GIVING CAN.
GENERALLY ALWAYS ATTEND ONE OF
THOSE COURSE OKAY YOU'RE NOT
LIKE COMPLETELY FULL OR THINGS
LIKE THAT NO WE CAN GENERALLY
ACCOMMODATE YEP PEOPLE IN THOSE
COURSES BUT DEFINITELY BUT LET'S
SAY IS HEY I REALLY NEED A
RESPITE OR INMIGRANTE COUNSELING
SERVICES.
SOMETHING VERY SPECIFIC --
I I NEED A RAMP PUT INTO MY HOME
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT WE MIGHT
LIMIT THOSE TYPE OF SERVICES AND
REALLY IT COMES DOWN --
TO YOU KNOW THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
YOU HAVE FOR WHAT PARTICULAR
SERVICES THAT THEY'RE IN NEED OF
SO.
NOT TRUE WEIGHTLESS IN OUR AREA
JUST AND AND HAVE A NICE BECAUSE
IT'S ACTUALLY SINCE THEIR
JACKSON'S IN HERE I KNOW SHE
SPOKE TO INCHES TALK WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT SO JUST ONE SMALL
PIECE IS ACTUALLY GETTING PEOPLE
TO KIND OF EQUIPMENT FOR THEM TO
BE SAFE AT HOME THE STAY.
AT HOME --
DEFYING --
YOU -- HAVE
GREATER DEMAND FOR THAT DO YOU
HAVE FOR PROVIDER --
HOW YEAH WELL I WAS THAT YEAH --
SO SYSTEM DEVICES AND SO RIGHT.
BARS ARAMBULA OR OR STUFF LIKE
THAT BODY CARE FOR I WOULD SAY
UP WHITE NEED A DOORWAY ON RAMP
YEAH OUT THERE'S A LOT OF DEMAND
FOR THAT AND WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT IF YOU'RE GONNA.
WHITE IN A DOORWAY OR NOT A RAMP
INTO A HOME AND YOU'RE LOOKING
AT ADA COMPLIANCE A CONTRACTOR
AND AND THAT TYPE OF STUFF YEAH
SO.
WE WILL DO EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN WE ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO LOOK
AT ALTERNATIVES SO I MEAN
OFTENTIMES WE'RE FULL PRESS ON
THIS EMPOWERMENT MODEL BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH RESOURCES TO
DO EVERYTHING IT'S DEFINITELY
NEEDED --
AND WE CAN PUT IT IN BUT WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO FULFILL EVERYONE'S
RECALLS.
SO WHAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL --
THIS WILL TRY TO YOUR ARMS
AROUND SOME OF THIS IS THAT.
IF THERE'S A WAY FOR THE FIVE
AGING THE AGING AGENCIES AND
OTHER SO MAYBE AT LEAST COME UP
WITH A IF I HAD A ROBUST FUN FOR
DISSIDENT VOICES MATERIAL AID
RAMPS STORE WAS AND THEN I WOULD
ADVERTISE FOR THAT AND SAY IF
YOU'RE A CARE GIVER.
AND YOU'RE HAVING PROBLEMS WITH
YOUR LOVED ONE AND HE NEED TO
WIDEN DOORWAY AND YOU NEED A A
GRAVEL BAR NAY CHAIR.
I CAN PUT IT IN RIGHT NOW I
WON'T GO OUT TO THE COMMUNITY
AND SAY THAT BECAUSE I WOULD BE
INUNDATED AND THEN I WOULD BE
TURNING PEOPLE AWAY.
SO I WAS A ROBUST FUND FOR THE
SERVICE SERVICES I GUESS MY
QUESTION TO YOU THAT IS HOW MUCH.
SO.
IF YOU WANT MY SERVICE --
WILL WITH THE WELL IT'S IS AND
WHAT TYPE THE WHOLE YEAH BUT
ACTUALLY NO I MEAN THAT'S
EXACTLY QUESTION SO SOMETIMES
WHAT HAPPENS IS FOR US RIGHT.
WE ACTUALLY WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
OKAY WELL GIVEN WHAT YOU DAILY
TO THE MAN THAT YOU SEE AND
MAYBE IT'S AND YOU WON'T SEE ALL
OF IT BUT AND HOW MUCH RIGHT I
MEAN RIGHT AT THAT SO AT LEAST
KNOW WHAT TO AIM FOR ME MID THAT
PROVIDE THAT.
MUCH BUT AT LEAST HAVE A BETTER
SENSE OF WHAT THE SCALE IS RIGHT
YEAH SURE SO MY SERVICE AREA I
WOULD SAY IF I COULD DEDICATE A
SOLID TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS I I THINK I COULD.
DO IT WITH CONTRACTOR FOR THE
TYPE OF WORK YOU DO WHICH ARE
RAMPS WIDENING DOORWAYS.
BARS ETCETERA NOW THAT'S MY
SERVICE AREA --
I IMAGINE LA COUNTY.
YEAH.
IT MIGHT BE A LOT DIFFERENT LOOK
AT AND SAY OKAY WELL YOU KNOW
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE OKAY.
BUT TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND MIGHT
BE MANAGED.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
SO WE HAVE A THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I WANNA THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS FOR FOR COMING HERE
TODAY ON THIS.
ISSUE THAT SERVE VERY NEAR AND
DEAR TO ME AND AND JOSEPH --
I AM VERY IMPRESSED WITH THE A
YEAR SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR BUDGET --
SERVING THE TWO OTHER PEOPLE
THAT YOU DEAL WITH IT AS SUCH A
LARGE DEGREE GEOGRAPHICAL AREA --
AND I LOVE YOUR ENTHUSIASM AS
WELL -- AND
SERAPH AYE KILEY SERRA YES YES
MISPRONOUNCING SO I PROCEEDED
YOUR YOUR PRESENTATION AND WHAT
I TOOK AWAY FROM YOUR
PRESENTATION IS THAT --
YOU KNOW.
SOMETIMES WE HAVE.
A PARENT OR AN AUNT THAT --
ULTIMATELY.
GETS AL'S ARMORS DISEASE IT
DOESN'T --
BECOME -- A
SERIES OF ANTI TELL SOMETHING
HAPPENS AS AN EXAMPLE MY DAD WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH ALZHEIMER'S WITH
THE LOS ANGELES RIVERSIDE COUNTY
I SOME ABOUT ONCE A MONTH AND
SAW THE STEADY.
DECLINE --
MY DAD WAS A TEETOTALER BUT ONE
OF THE SYMPTOMS OF OF OUTSIDERS
IS PEOPLE RESORT TO ALCOHOL
SOMETIMES BECAUSE THEY'RE
CONFUSED IT KIND OF EASES THEIR
CONFUSION.
MY DAD WAS DRIVING IN THE CITY
OF BELLE DOWN A ONE WAY STREET
AND GOT ARRESTED FOR DO YOU WHY
IT.
IS ALL SO THAT WAS A FLAG TO US
THAT OKAY WE KIDS NEED A SAMPLE
OF WE NEED.
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO TO TAKE CARE OF OUR PARENTS
AND AND WE DID IT AND WE HAVE
THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO DO IT
MY CONCERN IS WHAT YOU MENTIONED
THAT -- MANY
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHERE TO GO.
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW HOW TO GET THE
SERVICES.
AND THERE MAY BE A A LOT OF
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE IN
THE STATE THAT JUST FRANKLY
AREN'T BEING USE.
AND SO I WAS THINKING.
YOU KNOW.
PLACES WHERE PEOPLE WITH
DEMENTIA --
MAYBE SEE.
EMERGENCY ROOMS ASSISTED LIVING
CONVALESCENT HOMES.
WHAT CAN WE DO BETTER IN THE
STATE?
EVEN IF IT REQUIRES A
REQUIREMENT THAT WHEN YOU SEE
SOMEONE THAT IS NOT THE
DIAGNOSIS OF OF DEMENTIA AS
YOU'RE JUST CHARGING THEM BACK
INTO.
A RESIDENTIAL ENVIRONMENT.
THAT HERE ARE THE SERVICES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE.
MANY OF WHICH MAY BE FREE OF
CHARGE.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE CORD DEATH
COORDINATE THAT THROUGH COUNTIES
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT WE NEED.
TO NUMBER ONE OVERCOME LANGUAGE
BARRIERS AND WE NEED TO WRITE IT
IN LAYMAN'S TERMS SO THE PEOPLE
THAT MAYBE NOT TECH SAVVY.
CAN USE THEIR PHONE --
AND BE ABLE TO GET SOMEONE TO
COULD TALK TO THE MIDDLE LEVEL
THAT THEY CAN UNDERSTAND.
SO THAT THEY CAN EMBRACE THE
SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THEM IN THEIR TIME OF CRISIS SO
WHAT COULD WE DO IS A STATE TO
BETTER THAT COMMUNICATION TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR THE FOR
YOUNGSTERS OR OLDER PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO SAY I NEED HELP.
GRAHAM IS OUT OF CONTROL MOMS
OUT OF CONTROL YOU KNOW BY THE
ADAM AFRAID HE'S GONNA BURN THE
HOUSE DOWN EAGER TO FLAME ON IT
DOESN'T TURN HIM OFF IS MAKING
ITS MACARONI CHEESE.
YEAH WELL WELL THANK YOU SENATOR
STAND -- FOR
YOU KNOW SO ELOQUENTLY
SUMMARIZING THE ISSUE AND I
THINK YOU'VE REALLY HIT THE NAIL
ON THE HEAD WHICH IS.
A LOT OF THE TIMES THIS ISSUE
STARTS IN EITHER THE MEDICAL
OFFICE OR IN THE HOSPITAL WHEN
PEOPLE ARE WAITING DISCHARGED
HOME.
OR WHEN A FAMILY MEMBER IS --
WITH THEIR ALZHEIMER'S.
WELL DOCTOR WOULD WHY DO AND THE
DOCTOR CAN TELL YOU WHAT YOU CAN
DO TO CARE FOR YOUR MEDICAL
NEEDS BUT MOST OFTEN THEY DON'T
REALLY HAVE A CONNECTION TO THE
LONG TERM SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
SOCIAL SERVICE ARENA.
THAT RIGHT THERE IS A HUGE
BARRIER TO HELPING PEOPLE ACCESS
THE INFORMATION AND SUPPORTS
THEY NEED.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ONE
SOLUTION TO THAT PART YET BUT I
THINK THAT IT'S THE MORE THAT WE
CAN WITH RAISE AWARENESS AWARE
ROUND IT AND START TO ENGAGE THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM AND HOW TO
DEVELOP MORE INTEGRATED SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
THERE CERTAIN DEMONSTRATIONS
RIGHT NOW THAT ARE SEEKING TO DO
THAT IN THE STATE LIKE THROUGH
THE COORDINATED CARE INITIATIVE
BUT ULTIMATELY I THINK WE HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO.
BUT JUST I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
TO JUST IN THE IN THE FOCUS OF
AL SUMMERS GIVEN THAT THAT WAS
YOUR EXPERIENCE AS A FAMILY
MEMBER.
I'M AMAZED BY THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATIONS RESOURCE THAT THEY
HAVE IT'S AN EIGHT HUNDRED CALL.
A ONE EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBER THAT
YOU CAN USE FROM ANYWHERE IN THE
COUNTRY IF YOU ARE FAMILY MEMBER
LIKE YOURSELF.
AND YOU HAVE A QUESTION AND YOU
DON'T KNOW WHERE TO START --
YOU CAN ACCESS A TRAINED PERSON
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE LINE
THAT EITHER CONNECTION DIRECTLY
WITH YOUR LOCAL AREA OR IF
THEY'RE NOT OPEN.
THEY DO A WARM HAND OFF TO YOUR
REGIONAL OFFICE AND I KNOW THAT
MISS MARK HAS COULD SPEAK VERY
WELL TO THIS --
AND THEN THEY CAN DO AN IN HOME
ASSESSMENT TO SEE WHAT YOUR
LOVED ONE NEEDS IN THE HOME THEY
CAN GIVE YOU THE RESOURCES YOU
NEED THEY HAVE THE BACK.
END TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS ARE AVAILABLE IN YOUR
AREA TO CONNECT YOU WITH THEY
DON'T RECOMMEND ONE OVER THE
OTHER BUT THEY HAVE THOSE SORTS
OF RESOURCES DO THROUGH WHAT I
WAS TALKING ABOUT SAY THROUGH
THE NO WRONG DOOR SYSTEM --
OBVIOUSLY IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
HARD BECAUSE WE WOULD HAVE TO
RAMP UP A SYSTEM LIKE THAT BUT I
DON'T THINK IT HAS TO BE.
IMPOSSIBLE AND YOU KNOW THERE
ARE STATES SAYS THEY SAID THAT
HAVE FIGURE OUT WAYS TO DO THIS
WE JUST HAVE TO HAVE THE
INTENTION TO DO IT.
SO -- BUT I
DO THINK THAT.
THAT THIS IS AN AREA THAT
DESERVES A LOT OF LEADERSHIP AND
ATTENTION AND I'M GLAD TO SEE
THAT IT'S HIGHLIGHTED BY THE
COMMITTEE TODAY.
THANK APPREHENSION YOU'RE YOU'RE
ANSWERING THE QUESTION AND I
WOULD LOVE TO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND SEEING IF
WE CAN COME UP WITH SOME STATES
LUCIEN'S TO GET THAT INFORMATION
OUT.
THANK YOU THE INVENTOR.
YEAH I HAD A QUESTION --
YOU KNOW EVERY COUNTY HAS LIKE
OF MANAGEMENT TO KILL PLAN
PROGRAM.
HOW WHAT RELATIONSHIP DO YOU
HAVE?
IN SERVE A COORDINATED SYSTEM OF
CARE.
NO WRONG DOOR KIND OF MODEL WITH
THESE.
MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS
BECAUSE THAT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO RIGHT.
BUT HOW HOW HOW DO THEY HOW TO
THE INVOLVE THEMSELVES.
OF THIS ISSUE THE TRIP IT'S A
TERRIFIC QUESTION.
MEDICAL HELP.
RIGHT AS YOU SAID MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE IS IN ALL AREAS ALL
COUNTIES OF THE STATE NOW --
SENIORS AND PEOPLE DOES COUNTIES
DO A LEGIBLE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
OLDER ADULTS AND WITH --
ARE DUALLY ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE
MEDICARE.
ARE ONLY REQUIRED TO ENROLL IN
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE IN THIS
PART OF THIS COORDINATED CARE
INITIATIVE BUT T. ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION MORE FOCUSED --
IN A MORE FOCUSED WAY --
KILL MANAGED CARE HAS
TRADITIONALLY NOT ENGAGED ON
ISSUES OF LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
IT HASN'T BEEN UNTIL THERE WAS
THE SCORE NATIVE KAREN MISSION
RIGHT.
THAT THEY DO SO AND AND ONE
EXCEPTION BEING ACTUALLY THERE
SO MANY EXCEPTIONS --
IT IS THE COMMUNITY BASED ADULT
SERVICES PROGRAM WHICH IS
ACTUALLY.
TECHNICALLY A STATEWIDE --
BENEFIT AS PART OF MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE BUT THE CHALLENGES
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES
IS ONLY AVAILABLE IN SAFE THIRTY
EIGHT I THIRTY OF THE STATE'S
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
NOT TRULY A BENEFIT AND I COULD
GIVE OTHER EXAMPLES BUT LONG
STORY SHORT I THINK THAT THERE
IS A MOVEMENT TOWARDS HAVING
MANAGED.
L. T. S. AS THE SOCIAL SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM MORE INTEGRATED
WITHIN OUR MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE
SYSTEM BUT WE'RE NOT THERE YET.
AT ALL AND I THINK THERE'S A LOT
THAT WE CAN LEARN FROM --
THIS COORDINATED KERR IS ON A US
IS YOU'RE ONE OF THE CAN WE HAVE
THE RIGHT A SO SO I I'M
INTERESTED IN THE CASE WORKER
ASSIGNING.
YOU KNOW THE WANT YOU TO TALK
ABOUT THEM NO WRONG DOOR IT'S
KIND OF SOUNDS LIKE ACCORDING
CARE.
WHERE THEY COME IN AND THEN
THERE'S A CASE WORKER THEY
PACKAGE SHE?
A SAID OF LIKE WHAT WE USED TO
CALL WRAPAROUND RIGHT RIGHT
RIGHT.
KNOWN.
AS WE STARTED DOING NOW THE
NINETIES YOU KNOW.
AND THEN AND THEN WE WE PUT --
THAT SYSTEM TOGETHER COULD BE A
MULTI DISCIPLINARY SOCIAL
SERVICE THERE MIGHT BE SOME
FAMILY SUPPORT PROGRAM.
IT BE LIKE A WHOLE PACKAGE FOR
NOT JUST THE PATIENT THAT'S A
MEDICAL PATIENT WITH THE FAMILY
AND MEDICAL.
THEN WE INVOLVE THE FAMILY
TOGETHER IN THAT.
GOING THAT TOGETHER LIKE THE
FAMILY SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN THE
DISCUSSION ABSOLUTELY --
SO -- IS
THAT IS THAT KIND OF A SYSTEM
THAT SHOULD BE STATEWIDE --
GOSH I THINK IF WE CAN GET A
TRULY PERSON CENTERED SYSTEM OF
CARE LIKE THAT THAT LOOKS NOT
ONLY AT A PERSON'S MEDICAL NEEDS
BUT THE RANGE OF SOCIAL SERVICE.
YEAH BECAUSE AS WE KNOW IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT HEALTHCARE IT'S NOT
HOUSING IT'S BUT TRANSPORTATION
IT'S ABOUT CARE GIVING SUPPORT.
THE WHOLE RANGE FOOD SOCIAL
PROGRAM ORAL HEALTH MENTAL
HEALTH YOU NAME IT --
IT IN AGAIN THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE
COORDINATED CARE INITIATIVE BUT
I THINK WEARE A WAYS AWAY FROM
THAT RIGHT NOW FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS.
I ALSO THINK A GOOD MODEL AS
YOU'RE VERY FOR GET TO THE THE
WHOLE WRAPAROUND IN THE MEDICAL
SERVICE SIDE IS THE LANHAM ACT
BECAUSE THE REGIONAL SO I KNOW
YOU'RE VERY FAMILIAR WITH THAT.
THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM IS --
YOU KNOW FOR OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES THERE
THEY DON'T HAVE A SYSTEM LIKE
THAT THAT OFFERS THAT INTENSIVE
CASE MANAGEMENT PLANNING AS AN
ENTITLEMENT SO I THINK THERE'S A
LOT TO LEARN FROM.
THE STRENGTH OF THAT SYSTEM IN
AND HOW CAN WE HELP.
THE BROADER POPULATION AN ACCESS
SERVICE YOUR CENTER.
LATERAN ACT IS KIND OF LIKE THE
MALES KNOWS PRETTY GOOD IT NO
STARS.
TAKE CARE OF PEOPLE RIGHT THERE
STONE I WORK ON THAT
[inaudible]
OF I HAD I HAD A QUESTION ABOUT
INSURANCE COMPANIES --
PRIVATE INSURANCE COMPANIES
REQUIRED TO BE LICENSED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PROVIDE
[inaudible]
INSURANCE.
AND THEY'RE ALSO REQUIRED TO
OBSERVE OUR STATE LAWS AND IF
THEY WANT TO LICENSE AFTER
OBSERVERS STATE LAWS.
AND WE CALL THEM YOU KNOW.
SOME PEOPLE CALL THOSE LAWS
MANDATES ARE CALM STATE LAWS.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE NOT AND MANDATE
STIR YOU'RE REQUIRED TO FALL A
LAW IF YOU WANT TO DO BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA.
SO ARE THERE LAWS THAT PROTECT
AND PROVIDE FOR THIS KIND OF
CARE OR IS THERE ARE.
NOT ENOUGH --
SUPPORT.
FROM THE LAWS THAT WE HAVE. TO
REQUIRE THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
PRIVATE INSURANCE COMPANIES WILL
PROVIDE THE CARE I DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO ANSWER ME.
I YEAH I DON'T HAVE.
THE ONLY THING THAT I THAT I CAN
RELATE TO IT IS LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE WHICH I'M YES A MIST --
NINO WYLER HARLEM HER HER WELL
FROM A A. R. P. SPOKE.
BUT IN CALIFORNIA SO THAT THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE SUPPOSED
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
COMPANIES ARE.
THAT'S THEIR FOCUS IS HELPING
INDIVIDUALS FINANCE THEIR LONG
TERM CARE NEEDS LIKE WE'VE TO
DISCUSS TODAY THE CHALLENGES
THOSE.
THOSE --
MEANT MOST OF THOSE PLANS HAVE
BEEN ACTUAR EARLY CHALLENGED I
THINK IS ANICE WAY TO PUT IT.
AND ONLY ABOUT 5% WE GET THEIR
CARE FINANCED BY LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE SO THE MODEL HAS BEEN
PROVEN TO BE VERY FINANCIALLY
UNSOUND. FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS
AND THAT'S WHY IT YOU YOU SEE
INITIATIVES LIKETHOSE THAT
AREN'T ARE.
NOT SO MUCH THE LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE I'M TALKING ABOUT.
REGULAR HEALTH INSURANCE YEAH IF
I IF I BROTHER OF THESE OF YOU
KNOW OVERAGE TO PREVENT THE OR
SUPPORT.
THE PERSON THAT GOES INTO --
NEED A OF FAMILY CARE GIVER NAY
OF WHY I WOULD SAY WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE NOT SEEN IT AND I THINK
THE TESTIMONY TODAY WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HER GIVERS
WHENEVER WE TALK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW MEDI CAL MANAGED CARE
OR PRIVATE INSURANCE COMPANIES --
CARE GIVERS THERE'S NO SERVICE
FOR THEM TO THE INSURANCE
COMPANY AND AND SO I THINK
THAT'S YOU KNOW THE EMPHASIS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE STATE IS.
CARE GIVERS ARE STEPPING UP SO I
DON'T KNOW THAT INSURANCE AT
THIS TIME I DON'T SEE A PATH
THAT INSURANCE IS GOING TO
PROTECT CARE GIVERS.
AND IS GOING TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES THAT CARE GIVERS NEED
AND THAT'S WHAT MOST PEOPLE
TESTIFIED HERE TODAY IN THE
SERVICES THAT WE OFFER AS CARE
GIVER PROGRAMS.
IS IT'S FILLING THAT GAP AND I I
JUST DON'T SEE IT COMING FROM
MANAGER.
AND I DON'T SEE IT FROM THE
PRIVATE INSURANCE COMPANIES AS
WELL.
CAN AND EVEN THE SUCH IT ASKED
THE QUESTION EARLIER HOW.
I KNOW LIKE IN OUR AREA WE HAVE
MANAGED CARE BUT IT'S NOT AN
INTEGRATED SYSTEM IS NOT PART OF
CCI WHAT COUNTY ALL WEEK WELL I
INTERVIEWED COLUSA GLENN PLUMAS
STAINLESS SHASTA LAST MONEX
SISKIYOU IN TRINITY ---THERE ARE TWO DIFFERENT MANAGED
CARE PLANS IN THOSE AREAS AND
THEY TRY --
BUT THERE FUNDING ISN'T THERE WE
STILL HAVE CHALLENGES WITH
PEOPLE GETTING ACCESS TO THE
MEDICATION THEY NEED WE HAVE
CHALLENGES THAN GETTING
TRANSPORTATION SO.
I I DON'T THINK WE'RE THERE YET --
BY I THINK WE'RE A LONG WAY OFF
THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND WILL GO AHEAD AND
OPEN IT UP NOW TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
SO. FIFTY APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE STATE YOUR NAME.
AND AFFILIATION AND PLEASE KEEP
YOUR TESTIMONY TO TWO MINUTES.
THERE IN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DEBBIE TELL
IF I AM THE CEO OF TRACING AGING
WE'RE AT LONG TERM SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES PROVIDER IN.
CONTRA COSTA SOLANO NAPA AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTIES --
WE PROVIDE ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE
THE MULTI PURPOSE SENIOR
SERVICES PROGRAM CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY TRANSITIONS PROJECT.
AND CARE GIVER SUPPORT --
SERVICES THROUGH SUPPORT GROUPS
AND RETREATS AND I JUST WANNA
ECHO I'M SO GLAD THAT YOU HAD
SERRA HERE AND THE OTHER
PANELISTS BECAUSE THEY THINK
THAT.
YOU'VE GOT A REALLY CLEAR
PICTURE OF WHAT SOME OF THE
NEEDS ARE AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR ASKING ABOUT A HOLISTIC
APPROACH THIS BECAUSE MET LIFE
STUDIES SHOWED THE IMPACT ON THE
VERSE ARE OUT OF WORK BECAUSE
THERE CARE GIVING FOR SOMEBODY.
I THINK THAT THERE'S A SOLUTION
TO THIS PROBLEM THAT INVOLVES
MORE THAN THE GOVERNMENT
FIGURING OUT HOW TO TAX PEOPLE
BUT HOW TO GET COMMUNITIES AND
BUSINESSES TO RECOGNIZE.
THE LOSS IN REVENUE AS A RESULT
OF THAT AND PARTICIPATE IN HOW
WE FIGURE OUT HOW TO
HOLISTICALLY COVER WHAT CARE
GIVERS NEED AND I WOULD ALSO
JUST ECHO.
THE NEED FOR HAVING A ONE POINT
ENTRY SYSTEM WHAT YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT COMPLETELY ECHOES
WHAT THE LONG TERM CARE
INTEGRATION PROJECT DISCOVERED
IN TWO THOUSAND TWO WHICH IS WE
NEED A SINGLE POINT OF ENTRY AND
SOMEBODY WHO CAN.
TRAVEL ALONG WITH US THE WAY
LAST YEAR WE GOT --
LEGISLATION PASSED SO THAT CARE
GIVERS ARE AT WORK WERE ASKING
PATIENTS IF THEY HAVE CARE
GIVERS WE NEED TO GO THE NEXT
STEP WE NEED TO GET WE NEED TO
GET SERVICES TO THE CARE GIVERS
TO BE.
KEEP PEOPLE LIVING AT HOME
LONGER AND HAVE A BETTER
APPROACH TO IT AND I AM SO
HEARTENED BY THE DISCUSSION THAT
HAPPENED TODAY AND I JUST WANTED
TO THANK YOU --
CAROL SCHOOL I'M THE CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ELDER JUSTICE
COALITION AND ALSO STAFF TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
HEARING AND JUST TO MAKE NOTE
THAT --
KEVIN PRINTABLES THE ONLY PERSON
ON YOUR PANELS WHO MENTIONED THE
ISSUE OF ELDER ABUSE.
AND WHEN USED BEGIN TO LOOK AT
DATA ON ELDER ABUSE THE LARGEST
PERCENTAGE OF PERPETRATORS ARE
FAMILY MEMBERS.
AND IF YOU'RE PUTTING PEOPLE IN
SITUATIONS WHERE THEY'RE NOT
ADEQUATELY TRAINED AND NOT
PREPARED AND DON'T FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVE A CHOICE.
YOU ARE SETTING THEM UP FOR
FAILURE.
AND THAT'S REALLY A CRITICAL
THING TO FOCUS ON TO PROVIDE
TRAINING.
AND WHEN PEOPLE ARE CARE GIVERS
AND THEY GET INTO A SITUATION
THAT -- IS
DANGEROUS.
THE PULL THEM OUT AND TO GIVE
THEM THE SUPPORTS THAT THEY NEED --
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
CREATING.
ELDER ABUSE REGISTRIES AND
PENALIZING A LOCKING PEOPLE UP.
BUT WHEN THEY'RE NOT PREPARED TO
TAKE ON THE JOB THEY REALLY NEED
THE SUPPORT AND THE HELP TO TURN
THEM AROUND AND I'VE ACTUALLY
HEARD ABOUT --
I THINK IT WAS THE A JUDGE
INVENTOR OF WHO ACTUALLY HAS
SENTENCE --
CARE GIVERS WHO HAVE BEEN OF
VIOLENT OR ABUSIVE. TO TRAINING.
SO THAT THEY WILL GET WHAT THEY
NEED SO THEY CAN.
CARE FOR THEIR LOVED ONE
APPROPRIATELY AND GET THE CARE
THAT THEY NEED.
TO SO I HOPE THAT YOU CAN
INCORPORATE THIS IN ANY.
THOUGHTS THAT YOU HAVE ON GOING
IN THAT MAYBE THAT CALIFORNIA
OLDER JUSTICE COALITION COULD BE
A PART OF THAT DISCUSSION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON EVERYONE --
MANY MISSING MAKE BROOM AND I AM
THE PROGRAM MANAGER FOR THE DEL
MAR KICK OF A RESOURCE CENTER
ONE OF THE ELEVEN RESOURCE
CENTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I WANTED TO COME UP HERE
REPRESENT --
MY AGENCY AND MYSELF BECAUSE I
AM A MILLENNIAL CARE GIVER --
I'M CARING FOR MY MOTHER WHO WAS
MOTHER IN LAW WAS AT KNOWS AND
SHE LIVES WITH US AND PART OF
THE SANDWICH GENERATION AND
CARING FOR A FIVE MONTH OLD.
AND SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT --
SENATOR PAN AND CENTER JACKSON
HAD ASKED WERE SOLUTIONS HOW CAN
WE FIND SOLUTIONS AND AS A
PROGRAM MANAGER.
I SEE A LOT OF GAPS --
ONE OF THEM IS THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TRYING TO FIND A ONE WAY
SYSTEM TO IDENTIFY A NETWORK OF
REFERRALS.
MAYBE THAT.
EVERYBODY CAN POINT TOWARDS AND
THAT WE CAN --
REFER TO OTHER DIFFERENT
AGENCIES RIGHT NOW IT'S A VERY
FRAGMENTED SYSTEM AND WHAT I SEE
IS WORKING FROM THE MEDICAL
PERSPECTIVE IS WE SEE --
THE PILOT SYSTEMS WHERE --
NAVIGATORS ARE SENDING REFERRALS
OVER TO US AND WE THEN ARE ABLE
TO CATCH THESE.
EARLY ARE CARE GIVERS --
WITH EARLY ONSET OF MALE COTTON
AS WE GET THOSE ARE CARE GIVERS
AND REYES ABLE TO EDUCATE THEM.
BUT THE PROBLEM THAT WE ALSO SEE
IS THAT THERE'S A BIG GAP WITH
MILLENNIAL CARE GIVERS --
MOST OF OUR CLIENTS ARE OLDER
CARE GIVER SPOUSAL CAREGIVERS --
WE HAVE --
CARE GIVERS WHO ARE CHILDREN BUT
THEY DON'T COME TO A LOT OF OUR
SUPPORT GROUP THEY DON'T COME TO
OUR EDUCATION AND TRAINING
CLASSES EVEN THOUGH IT'S FREE --
BECAUSE QUITE FRANKLY --
WE ARE NOT TALKING THE SAME
PLATFORM THAT THEY'RE RECEIVING
INFORMATION FROM --
AS A MILLENNIAL CARE GIVER I GO
TO FACEBOOK I GO TO THE
PLATFORMS AND THERE ARE JUST NOT
ENOUGH PLATFORMS.
ARE CURRENTLY WITHIN OUR OUR
SYSTEM R. E. SYSTEM TO BE ABLE
TO CATER TO THE WAY THAT THEY
NEED INFORMATION.
AND I THINK PART OF THE ISSUE IS
THAT THEY DON'T AYE DIFFERENT
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES AS A CARE
GIVER.
AND I KNOW THAT.
IN AUSTRALIA THEY DID A
NATIONWIDE CAMPAIGN WITH
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION WHERE
THEY HIRED A CELEBRITY WHO WAS
ALSO A CARE GIVER --
AND HE WAS YOUNGER AND HE TALKED
ABOUT HIS EXPERIENCE AND IS A
NATIONWIDE CAMPAIGN AND IT
BROADENED THE AWARENESS AND IT
WAS AN INITIATIVE.
BY YOU KNOW AUSTRALIA AND
ALZHEIMER'S IS A SO I THINK THAT
WE NEED TO LOOK AT A PREVENTIVE.
STANDPOINT AND WE ALSO NEED TO
LOOK AT IT AS YOU KNOW
INTEGRATING NEW TECHNOLOGIES TO
REACH A YOUNGER DEMOGRAPHIC
BECAUSE THEY WE ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE GOING TO BE CONTINUING
TO PROVIDE CARE. FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS SO OUR AGENCY IS ASKING
FOR A TEN MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING
FOR THE NEXT THREE YEARS TO HELP
US READ REVAMPS RETOOL OUR
PLATFORM.
SO THAT WE CAN YOU KNOW PROVIDE
ALL THE DIFFERENT NEW SYSTEMS TO
INTEGRATE YOU KNOW --
EDUCATION THROUGH MULTI
LANGUAGES ACROSS ALL THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES I ALSO THINK
THAT PROFESSIONAL AN INFORMAL
FAMILY CAREGIVERS SHOULD BE
REIMBURSED IN SOME WAY --
RIGHT NOW I JUST US THEY'D BE
THERE IS A LACK OF PROVIDERS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T GET PAID.
HARDLY ANYTHING --
A SO WHY WOULD THEY WANT TO GO
AND PROVIDE CARE GIVING WHEN
THEY COULD GO TO STARBUCKS AND
MAKE SIXTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR.
AND THEY'RE GONNA GET BETTER
BENEFITS AND CARE GIVING IS A
HARD JOB.
SO WE NEED TO SOMEHOW REIMBURSE
THEM -- WE
ALSO NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT MEDI
CAL MEDICARE AND THE FUNDING OF
LONG TERM CARE PLACEMENT.
RIGHT NOW THERE'S A GAP IT'S
JUST NOT WORKING EITHER OU MAKE
SPEND ON YOUR MONEY AND BE AND
POVERTY IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
MEET BE MEDI CAL.
SO THAT YOU CAN GET LONG TERM
CARE AND THE SOLUTION THERE'S
JUST I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
SOLUTION IS BUT IT'S NOT THERE --
AND ALSO --
WORKING WITH OUR TRIPLE A.'S.
OUT H. C. B. S. REFERRAL SYSTEM
SOME SORT OF UNIFIED PERCENT
REFERRAL SYSTEM UP. ONE POINT
ENTRY SYSTEM THAT IS INTEGRATED
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE ENTIRE --
STATE.
COUNTY I DON'T NOW TO SOMETHING --
HAVE A BETTER ACCESS FOR ALL OF
OUR CLIENTS TO KNOW AND TO BE
REFERRED OVER TO OUR AGENCIES
LIKE CRC OR ELDER DAY FOR MS AS
P. -- THINGS
OF THAT NATURE THEM THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
WHAT WE'VE HEARD A LOT TODAY I
THINK YOU FOR THE INFORMATION
FOR PROTECT YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND TESTIMONY?
OF WE WILL.
YOUR TICKET BACK TO OUR OFFICES
AND CONSIDER HOW BEST TO MOVE
FORWARD CLEARLY THE SERVICE THAT
FAMILY CAREGIVERS PROVIDE IS
INVALUABLE ON A PERSONAL LEVEL
TO THE CARE RECIPIENT BUT ALSO
ON A SOCIETAL LEVEL.
AS WE BUILD A SYSTEM THAT
ENABLES OUR AGING ADULTS TO LIVE
IN THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES IN
THEIR OWN HOMES.
ON THEIR OWN TERMS OTHER
MULTIPLE EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF AGING UP POPULATION
UNDER WAY INCLUDING DISCUSSIONS
TO DEVELOP THE MASTER PLAN ON
AGING.
THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE WILL ALSO BE FOCUSING
ON AGING ISSUES THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR.
INCLUDING POTENTIALLY HOLDEN
ADDITIONAL INFORMATIONAL
HEARINGS.
AS WE'VE HEARD THE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORTS FOR OLDER ADULTS IS
COMPLICATED IT CAN BE DIFFICULT
TO NAVIGATE.
WITH THIS IN MIND I HAVE
INTRODUCED US BEFORE FIVE THREE
WHICH BOLSTERS THAT NO WRONG
DOOR APPROACH TO SERVING OLDER
ADULTS AND FAMILY MEMBERS --
NO WRONG DOOR IS THE MODEL USED
IN AGING AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CENTERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HAS BEEN SHOWN TO BE EFFECTIVE
IN CONNECTING OLDER ADULTS TO
LOCALLY AVAILABLE SERVICES AND
INFORMATION.
REGARDLESS OF INCOME OR BENEFIT
LEVEL I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU AS THIS BILL AND OTHERS --
MOVED TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCSS
PROCESS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE TODAY